When does fast delivery through Instacart matter most? When your famous grainy mustard potato salad isn't so famous without its grainy mustard. When the barbecues lit, but there's nothing to grill. When the in-laws decide that, actually, they will stay for dinner. Instacart has all your groceries covered this summer. So download the app and get delivery in as fast as 60 minutes. Plus, enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders, service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver.
Instacart 的快速送达服务在什么时候最重要？当你那著名的粗芥末土豆沙拉因为少了粗芥末而不再出名时。当烧烤架已经点燃，却没什么可烤的时候。当你的姻亲突然决定，其实他们今晚要留下来吃晚饭时。这个夏天，Instacart 能满足你所有的杂货需求。所以，下载应用程序，最快 60 分钟即可送达。此外，前三单还可享受 0 美元配送费，服务费、除外条款和适用条款请见详情。Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。
This episode is brought to you by Defender. With a towing capacity of 3,500 kilograms and a waiting depth of 900 millimeters, the Defender 110 pushes what's possible. Learn more at landrover.ca. Welcome back to the second drink of Phyllis's wedding. Man, is this a good episode? Oh, I love it. We have director Ken Whittingham, who joined us and shared his memories from
本集由 Defender 赞助播出。Defender 110 拥有 3500 公斤的牵引能力和 900 毫米的涉水深度，不断突破极限。详情请访问 landrover.ca。欢迎回到“菲利斯的婚礼”第二杯酒环节。天哪，这一集是不是很棒？哦，我太喜欢了。导演肯·惠廷汉姆加入了我们，分享了他执导这一集的回忆。
directing it. He gave us some of his personal photos from filming. We put that in our Instagram when this first aired. Oh, yeah. Ken is the best. Well, listen, for this second drink, I thought we could start with the Dwight deleted talking head that really made me laugh. So you remember how Dwight is making sure no one crashes the wedding. And then he sees an old man putting bread in his pockets and he thinks he's the wedding crasher. Well, in this talking head, he shares how he identifies a suspect. Oh, I caught the wedding crasher. Some people say it's the one you least suspect. Others say it's the one you most suspect.
他提供了拍摄时的一些个人照片。这一集首播时，我们把这些照片发到了 Instagram 上。哦，没错。肯是最棒的。好了，听着，对于这第二杯酒，我想我们先从那个真正让我大笑的德怀特删减版采访片段开始。你还记得德怀特是如何确保没人闯入婚礼的吗？然后他看到一个老人在口袋里装面包，就以为他是婚礼闯入者。在这个采访片段中，他分享了他是如何识别嫌疑人的。哦，我抓住了婚礼闯入者。有人说，最不可能的人往往就是嫌疑人。也有人说，最明显的人才是嫌疑人。
I neither suspected nor didn't suspect this guy. That's how I knew he was my suspect. Oh, isn't that great? That's amazing. I also have to think as an actor that that was probably really hard to memorize because you're taking the same phrase and twisting it only slightly with each sentence and then just flipping a few words around. And those are the ones that are always trickier.
我既没有怀疑也没有不怀疑这家伙。这就是我怎么知道他就是我的嫌疑人的。哦，这不是很棒吗？太神奇了。作为一名演员，我不得不认为这可能很难背诵，因为你用同样的短语，每句话只做一点点扭曲，然后只是调换几个词。而那些总是最棘手的。
for me. Yeah. Yeah. But Rain, of course, nailed it. Well, we got a fun fan letter I wanted to share because in this breakdown, we talk about how couples' names get mashed together, like Phyllis and Bob becoming flob. And then you and I talked about, like, who were the first celebrity couples to famously have their names mashed together? And, Angela, you said the first one was Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez. But Savannah C wrote in to say, What about Desi Lou? Desi Arnaz and Lucille Ball had the first celebrity mashup name. Oh, my gosh, Savannah.
对我来说。是的。是的。但雷恩当然演得非常到位。好吧，我们收到了一封有趣的粉丝来信，我想分享一下，因为在这次解析中，我们谈到了情侣的名字是如何合并在一起的，比如菲利斯和鲍勃变成了 Flob。然后你和我谈到了，谁是第一对以名字合并而闻名的名人情侣？安吉拉，你说第一对是本·阿弗莱克和詹妮弗·洛佩兹。但萨凡纳·C 写信来说，Desi Lou 呢？德西·阿纳兹和露西尔·鲍尔才是第一对拥有名人合并名字的情侣。哦，天哪，萨凡纳。
Of course they did. Desi Lou. Of course. Now, do we think they really are the first one? Is there anyone before Desi Lou? I mean, probably. Are you Googling? I am.
当然是他们。Desi Lou。当然。那么，我们认为他们真的是第一对吗？在 Desi Lou 之前还有别人吗？我的意思是，可能有吧。你在用谷歌搜索吗？我在搜。
What about in ye olden times where things weren't documented? And you just had like a bar wench named Rachel and then you had a squire. named Beckett. What about those people? And they were called Reckett. Nothing. Do you think that that really happened? I'm just saying there probably were other name mashups that we don't have documented. Well, I'm getting nowhere in my Google search. Desilu was probably the first real big one. I mean, I think that was even the name of their production company, right? Desi Lou Productions. Oh, was it? It flashed up on the TV after I Love Lucy. Okay.
那在古代，事情没有记录的时候呢？你只是有一个叫瑞秋的酒吧女招待，然后有一个叫贝克特的侍从。那些人呢？他们被称为 Reckett。什么都没有。你认为那真的发生过吗？我只是说可能还有其他我们没有记录的名字合并。好吧，我的谷歌搜索一无所获。Desilu 可能是第一个真正的大牌。我的意思是，我想那甚至就是他们制作公司的名字，对吧？Desi Lou Productions。哦，是吗？《我爱露西》之后它在电视上闪现过。好吧。
Well, I was curious about this question from Chia R, who said, Why was Pam and Roy's song a breakup song? It is? I didn't know, so I went back and I watched the episode. So you remember how Roy pays the band $20 to play You Were Me by Jewel? Yeah. And Pam is so moved because it's their song and they have this sweet dance. Well, I looked up the song lyrics.
嗯，我对 Chia R 的这个问题很好奇，她说，为什么帕姆和罗伊的歌是一首分手歌？是吗？我不知道，所以我回去看了那一集。你还记得罗伊付给乐队 20 美元让他们演奏 Jewel 的《You Were Me》吗？是的。帕姆非常感动，因为那是他们的歌，他们跳了一支甜蜜的舞。嗯，我查了这首歌的歌词。
And I didn't remember it as a breakup song, but it clearly is. And according to the internet, this is what it says about the song. It describes a failed relationship and the narrator's inadequate attempts at moving on with her life. Well, that's appropriate. Isn't that interesting? It really, really is. What do you guys know about that song? Sam, do you know this song, Cassie?
我不记得它是一首分手歌，但它显然是。根据互联网的说法，关于这首歌是这样写的。它描述了一段失败的关系，以及叙述者在继续生活方面所做的不足的尝试。嗯，那很贴切。这不有趣吗？真的，真的很有趣。你们对那首歌了解多少？萨姆，你知道这首歌吗，凯西？
Yeah, I know this song. It's Jewel, right? Yeah, it's Jewel. Yeah, I know this song. I remember it. Let's hear it. I hear the clock at 6 a. I feel so far from where I have.
是的，我知道这首歌。是 Jewel 的，对吧？是的，是 Jewel。是的，我知道这首歌。我记得。让我们听听。我听到凌晨 6 点的钟声。我感觉离我所在的地方很远。
I've got my eggs, I got my pancakes too. I've got my maple syrup, everything but you. I break the oaks and make a smiley face. I kinda like it in my brand new place. Swipe the spots above the mirror. Don't leave my keys in the door. I never put wet towels on the floor anymore because trains last so long.
我有鸡蛋，也有煎饼。我有枫糖浆，除了你什么都有。我打破橡木，做了一个笑脸。我有点喜欢我这个全新的地方。擦掉镜子上的斑点。别把钥匙留在门上。我再也不会把湿毛巾放在地板上了，因为火车持续了太久。
So long, even after your God, I know that you love me, and so you will see, you're meant for me, and that I was meant for you. She has moved out. She's making breakfast by herself. She doesn't put wet towels on the floor anymore. I don't know what that's about. I mean, probably he gave her shit about it. Probably.
太久了，即使在你上帝之后，我知道你爱我，所以你会看到，你是为我而生的，而我是为你而生的。她搬出去了。她独自做早餐。她不再把湿毛巾放在地板上了。我不知道那是什么意思。我的意思是，可能他因为这个骂过她。可能吧。
She does things the way she wants to do it now. But she is forlorn. This is Pam and Roy's song. Also, first of all, Jewel is amazing. Yeah. Like, stop it. I need to get more of her music, like, on my playlist because, wow. Oh, she was on the playlist.
她现在按自己想要的方式做事。但她很忧郁。这是帕姆和罗伊的歌。另外，首先，Jewel 太棒了。是的。就像，别说了。我需要把她的更多音乐放到我的播放列表中，因为，哇。哦，她在播放列表里。
I mean, back in the day, we all love some Jewel and we all wanted to, like, dress like her. Don't you remember? Oh, yeah. Yeah. Wow. Mm-hmm. Chaya, I thought that was a great catch. Well, before we go, I just want to share a sweet note that we got from Jennifer T.
我的意思是，在过去，我们都喜欢 Jewel，我们都想打扮得像她一样。你不记得了吗？哦，是的。是的。哇。嗯哼。Chaya，我觉得这是一个很棒的发现。好吧，在我们走之前，我只想分享一封我们从詹妮弗·T 那里收到的甜蜜便条。
who wrote in to say, I thought you should know that my husband's grandparents' names are Bob and Phyllis. That is so sweet. That's so sweet. Love that. Well, I have a did you know question for you, and it involves the famous Phyllis Michael scene before the wedding. Oh, the one where Michael says she tooted. Yes. What is it?
她写信说，我想你应该知道，我丈夫的祖父母的名字是鲍勃和菲利斯。那太甜了。太甜了。喜欢这个。好吧，我有一个“你知道吗”的问题要问你，它涉及婚礼前著名的菲利斯和迈克尔的场景。哦，就是迈克尔说她放屁的那一段。是的。是什么？
Well, when I was looking up these second drink tidbits, I went to the script to see if there was anything I missed. And I wanted to read you this description that is in the script, okay, about this Michael Phyllis fart joke. Okay. All right. It was scene 19, and this was noted in the script. Greg's note, semicolon, this scene should be shot in such a way that in editing the fart aspect of the scene can be cut out entirely. Like maybe we weren't going to have the fart part. It goes on to say, a no fart version is listed beneath the fart version. What?
嗯，当我在查找这些第二杯酒的趣闻时，我看了剧本，看看有没有我漏掉的东西。我想读给你听剧本里关于这个迈克尔和菲利斯放屁笑话的描述，好吗？好的。好的。那是第 19 场，剧本里有标注。格雷格的注释，分号，这一幕的拍摄方式应该是在剪辑时可以将放屁的部分完全剪掉。就像也许我们不打算加入放屁的部分。它接着说，放屁版本下面列出了一个无放屁版本。什么？
Yes. Do you want to hear the no fart version? Yes, I do. Interior Church dressing room, Michael. There she is. Phyllis is applying lipstick. Michael says, So help me, Phyllis, you're as beautiful as the day you started work at Dunder Mifflin.
是的。你想听无放屁版本吗？是的，我想听。内景，教堂更衣室，迈克尔。她在那儿。菲利斯正在涂口红。迈克尔说，帮帮我，菲利斯，你和你在邓德·米夫林开始工作的那天一样美丽。
Phyllis, thank you, Michael. sweet same as when you set it outside he pulls up a chair and takes her hand tenderly michael says how are you doing are you excited phyllis says yes very michael says me too if you need to throw up that's okay i did do you want to talk about tonight phyllis says no michael says i'm sure you're worried that you won't be able to please him and then he takes a beat he looks at her and says are you set on this hairstyle? And then Michael brushes her bangs, a skew with his fingers. It looks far worse.
菲利斯，谢谢你，迈克尔。和你刚才说的一样甜。他拉过一把椅子，温柔地握住她的手。迈克尔说，你怎么样？你兴奋吗？菲利斯说，是的，非常兴奋。迈克尔说，我也是。如果你需要呕吐，没关系，我吐过。你想谈谈今晚吗？菲利斯说，不。迈克尔说，我肯定你担心你不能取悦他，然后他停顿了一下。他看着她说，你确定要这个发型吗？然后迈克尔用手指拨乱了她的刘海。看起来更糟了。
Michael says, there, much better. And then Bob comes to the door. Wow. There you go. The no fart alt. It's literally called Michael Phyllis No Fart Alt. Oh my goodness. Yeah, I guess they couldn't decide which version they were going to use,
迈克尔说，好了，好多了。然后鲍勃来到门口。哇。给你。无放屁的替代版本。它字面上就叫“迈克尔和菲利斯无放屁替代版”。哦，天哪。是的，我想他们无法决定使用哪个版本，
and they used the fart version. Well, I loved all of that. That was a very good second drink. So now here is our breakdown of Phyllis's wedding. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the office ladies. Hey lady. Hey lady. How are you? I'm good. I'm taking an Instagram video. What? They can't hear you, though, on my video. I can hear you in my headphones. I was doing all these little dance moves. Oh, I miss that. Right before we record, Sam plays a little bit of Creed song, our music. And Jenna and I kind of just bop around and we kind of just helps us get into the episode. Every week, we danced a Creed song. Love it. Well, what are we talking? talking about this week, Angela? Oh, Jenna, I am so excited because we are talking about Phyllis's wedding. I love it so much. It's so good. This is season three, episode 15, written by Carolyn Williams, and directed by Ken Whittingham. Summary. Do it. Phyllis and Bob Vance of Vance
最后他们用了放屁的版本。好吧，我喜欢所有这些。那是一杯非常好的第二杯酒。所以现在这是我们对“菲利斯的婚礼”的解析。我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在为你制作终极《办公室》重温播客。每周，我们都会解析一集《办公室》，并分享只有两个在场的人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。嘿，女士。嘿，女士。你好吗？我很好。我正在拍 Instagram 视频。什么？但在我的视频里他们听不到你说话。我可以在耳机里听到你。我刚才在做所有这些小舞蹈动作。哦，我想念那个。就在我们录音之前，萨姆会播放一点 Creed 的歌，我们的音乐。珍娜和我就会跟着跳，这有助于我们进入状态。每周，我们都会跳 Creed 的歌。喜欢它。好吧，我们这周在谈论什么，安吉拉？哦，珍娜，我太兴奋了，因为我们在谈论“菲利斯的婚礼”。我太喜欢它了。太棒了。这是第三季第 15 集，由卡罗琳·威廉姆斯编剧，肯·惠廷汉姆执导。摘要。开始吧。菲利斯和万斯制冷的鲍勃·万斯要结婚了。今天就是这一天。菲利斯请迈克尔推她父亲的轮椅走过过道。但在菲利斯的父亲决定自己走过过道后，迈克尔感到不安，试图抢风头，最终被德怀特赶出了招待会。与此同时，帕姆对吉姆和凯伦的关系以及菲利斯偷走了她所有的婚礼创意感到难过和不安，她和罗伊一起离开了招待会。我忘了帕姆和罗伊一起离开了。我忘了。我也是。而我就是帕姆。不过这太棒了。太棒了。但这难道不会发生吗？就像如果你和某人在一起很长时间，然后你们分手了，在你们真正分手之前，你们会复合几次，对吧？那是真实的。
Refrigeration are getting married. Today is the day. Phyllis has asked Michael to push her father's wheelchair down the aisle. But after getting upset, staged when Phyllis's dad decides to walk down the aisle, Michael tries to steal the show and is eventually bounced from the reception by Dwight. In the meantime, Pam is sad and upset by Jim and Karen's relationship and the fact that Phyllis stole all of her wedding ideas and she leaves the reception with Roy. I forgot that Pam left with Roy. I forgot. Me too. And I'm Pam. It's so good though. It's so good. But doesn't that happen? Like if you've been with someone a really long time and then you break up, you get back together a couple times before you really break up, right? That's real.
特别是你在婚礼上，周围都是情侣，而你想在一起的那个人似乎不想和你在一起。突然之间，你知道坐在你身边的那个人就在那里，所以你会想，好吧，好吧，我觉得想来点爱。是的，我想是吧。哦。好吧。好吧，听着，第一个快速事实。很多人写信来，Sovereign Hurley, Ellie Trevelyan, Winter Pulver, Leah Barbaro, Tia Minoski 等等，想知道婚礼是在哪里拍摄的。但后来 Colby Linderman, Dana Hill, Christina, Carolyn 和 Jennifer 都想知道是不是吉姆和帕姆举行婚礼的同一个教堂，因为它们看起来非常相似。不是同一个教堂。不是同一个教堂。但听着，在我告诉你菲利斯的婚礼是在哪里拍摄之前，我们收到了更多关于它的邮件，好吗？
Especially you're at a wedding and there's all these couples and the person you want to be with doesn't seem like they want to be with you. All of a sudden, the thing that you know is sitting right next to you so you're like, well, okay, I feel like having some loving. Yeah, I guess. Oh. All right. Well, listen, fast fact number one. A lot of people wrote in, Sovereign Hurley, Ellie Trevelyan, Winter Pulver, Leah Barbaro, Tia Minoski, and many more want to know where was the wedding filmed. But then Colby Linderman, Dana Hill, Christina, Carolyn, and Jennifer all wanted to know is at the same church where Jim and Pam had their wedding because they look very similar. It is not the same church. It's not the same church. But listen, before I tell you where Phyllis's wedding was filmed, we got even more mail about it, okay?
Charis 写信说，在某个时候，菲利斯和帕姆都说她们是长老会教徒。婚礼是在真正的长老会教堂拍摄的吗？我猜答案是肯定的，因为剧组非常注重细节，而且长老会教堂喜欢栗色的地毯。Chris Furr 说，我是基督教会基督门徒会的一名牧师，这是一个小型新教教派，不到一百万人，主要在美国和加拿大。在这一集中，当菲利斯和鲍勃切婚礼蛋糕时，在 20 分 32 秒左右，门徒会的标志清晰可见。
Charis wrote in to say, at some point, Phyllis and Pam both say they are Presbyterians. Was the wedding filmed at an actual Presbyterian church? I'm guessing the answer is yes, because the crew pays a lot of attention to detail, and Presbyterian churches love maroon carpet. Chris Furr said, I am a pastor in the Christian Church Disciples of Christ, a small Protestant denomination, less than a million people, mostly in the U.S. and Canada. In this episode, the Disciples logo is clearly visible around the 20-minute, 32-second mark as Phyllis and Bob are cutting their wedding cake.
我很好奇从道具的角度来看，把那个特定的横幅留在背景中的选择。它是发光的，而且非常独特。所以他接着说，有趣的是，从神学上讲，对于喜欢保持“辛辣”的信义宗和一位论派信徒来说，这将是一个完美的妥协选择。如果能有任何背景信息会很酷，因为它在我们小小的门徒家庭中很受欢迎。是的，我们在北好莱坞的第一基督教堂拍摄了菲利斯的婚礼，它位于 Studio City，他们是一个基督门徒会教堂。
I was curious about the choice to leave that specific banner in the background from a prop point of view. It's lighted and it's pretty distinctive. So he goes on to say, the funny thing about it is that, theologically, this would be a perfect compromise choice for a Lutheran and a Unitarian who like to keep things, quote unquote, spicy. Any background on this would be cool as it is a big hit with our little disciples family. Yes, we filmed Phyllis's wedding at the first Christian church of North Hollywood, which is located in Studio City, and they are a Disciples of Christ Church.
是的。所以当我刚搬到洛杉矶时，我在寻找复活节礼拜的地方。我开车四处转，经过了这个教堂。这是一个非常美丽的教堂。你知道，它是红砖的，有一个尖顶。它看起来非常像教堂的样子。你知道我的意思吗？是的。我开车经过它，他们有一个关于复活节礼拜的大牌子。我想，哦，好吧，我会去那里参加复活节礼拜。我去了。而且非常好。好吧，我再给你一个关于这个教堂的有趣事实，Ang。什么？这是肯·萨博纳克和他妻子雪莉结婚的地方。哦，得了吧。你猜怎么着？他们刚在去年五月庆祝了结婚 30 周年纪念日。哦，那太棒了。
Yes. So when I first moved to LA, I was looking for somewhere to go for Easter services. And I was driving around and I drove past this church. And it's such a beautiful church. You know, it's the red brick and it has a steep. It looks very much like that is what a church looks like. You know what I mean? Yeah. And I drove past it and they had a big sign about their Easter service. And I thought, oh, well, I'll go there for Easter services. And I did. And it was very nice. Well, I'll give you another little fun fact about this church, Ang. What? This is where Kent Sabornack and his wife, Shelly, got married. Oh, come on. And guess what? They just celebrated their 30th wedding anniversary this past May. Oh, that's so great.
那太可爱了。恭喜你们。然后，伙计们，招待会在二楼的社交大厅举行。所以我们能够在这个教堂拍摄所有东西。是的，他们有一个联谊大厅。而且他们有，你知道，他们有像菲利斯准备的那种房间。是的。你知道，所有这些都已经在这个教堂里了。嗯，顺便说一句，多年后，我在那个大厅里为我的电视剧《分裂在一起》拍摄了一场学校独奏会场景。我们化妆和发型的候场室就是菲利斯在婚礼前准备的那个房间。而且有那个著名的迈克尔的场景。我当时在给每个人发短信。我当时在轰炸每个人的短信。我说，我在发生放屁的那个房间里。关于那个教堂还有另一件小事。我有一天独自在那里拍摄，因为那是菲利普去日托的地方。哦。好吧，你准备好迎接第二个快速事实了吗？我准备好了。我们联系了菲利斯。这是菲利斯的婚礼。我知道。我们怎么能不和菲利斯谈谈呢，伙计们？我们太激动了。所以菲利斯回到了圣路易斯。她几年前半永久地搬回了那里。她发来了一些音频片段。所以我们问菲利斯的第一个问题就是，拿到这个剧本并穿上婚纱是什么感觉？这是有趣的事情。珍娜、菲利斯和我是在婚礼上扮演重要角色的三位演员。这有点像这就是你的婚礼，因为它都是关于你的。这真的很有趣。是的。好吧。所以，萨姆，播放她的片段。嗨，女士们。我是菲利斯·史密斯，我们即将被称为万斯制冷的菲利斯·拉平·万斯，至少在这一集之后，对吧？当我看到剧本时，我太激动了。说实话。每次我们进行剧本朗读时，我们都会来到桌子旁，看剧本，看看我们有多少台词。所以我真的很兴奋，当我看到我要嫁给我一生的挚爱时，我感到很惊讶，整整一集。我真的很享受这一切。你问我的裙子。嗯，在那些日子里，听起来像黑暗时代，但那是 2000 年代初。大码女性没有太多选择。我们看起来要么像祖母，要么像曾祖母，要么像新娘。对于身材魁梧的新娘来说，没有太多选择。所以我很高兴我有一件看起来很漂亮而且很舒服的裙子。我必须向服装组致敬。他们真的，真的照顾我。每次我不得不去洗手间或任何事情时，你知道，他们就在那里帮助我处理一切。但是是的，在那些日子里，我没有太多选择。所以我只是想确保我的手臂被遮住。我对在镜头前和公共场合露手臂有点介意。至于裙子，是的，我很满意。它相当舒服。就像我说的，服装组真的照顾我。他们每一秒都在那里。
That's so lovely. Congratulations, you guys. And then, guys, the reception took place in their social hall, which was on the second floor. So we were able to film everything at this one. church. Yes, they have a fellowship hall. And they had, you know, they had the rooms like where Phyllis gets ready. Yeah. You know, all of that was already at this church. Well, incidentally, years later, we filmed a school recital scene for my TV shows splitting up together in that sort of hall. And our holding room for hair and makeup was that same room where Phyllis is
哦，我觉得她在这一集中看起来很华丽。她看起来太美了。这是我一段时间以来第一次听到菲利斯的声音。珍娜，当我第一次听到她发过来的音频时，它真的让我流泪了。是的。你只是，你可以听到菲利斯纯粹的，她只是一个纯洁的灵魂。你知道我的意思吗？当你听到她说话时，你就能感觉到。你知道我最喜欢那段音频片段的哪一部分吗，Ange，就是她称自己为万斯制冷的菲利斯·拉平·万斯。我知道。她把它加到了最后。我知道。我喜欢它。好吧，听到菲利斯的声音太有趣了。
getting ready before her wedding. And there's that famous scene with Michael. And I was like texting. everybody. I was like blowing up everyone's text. I'm like, I'm in the room where the fart happened. Here's another little thing about that church. I filmed there one day by myself because it's where Philip went to daycare. Oh. Well, are you ready for fast fact number two? I am. We reached out to Phyllis. It's Phyllis's wedding. I know. How could we not talk to Phyllis, you guys? We are so thrilled. So Phyllis is back in St. Louis. She moved back there semi-permanently a couple of years ago. And she sent in some audio clips. So the first thing we asked Phyllis was just what was it like to get this script and wear a wedding gown? Here's the fun thing. Jenna, Phyllis, and I are the three cast members that had big weddings. And it's kind of like it is your wedding because it's all about you. It's kind of really fun. Yes. All right. So, Sam, play her clip. Hi, ladies. It's Phyllis Smith, our soon to be known as Phyllis Lapin Vance of Vance
她发来了几个音频片段，伙计们。所以我们会在这一集中听到她的声音。哦，她发来了一些好东西。是的。第三个快速事实是这一集的导演肯·惠廷汉姆加入了我们的采访。肯执导了《办公室》的几集，我们只是爱他。演员们爱肯。萨姆播放采访。
Refrigeration, at least after this episode, right? I was so thrilled when I saw the script. Let's be truthful. Every time we had a table read, we'd all get to the table, look at the script, and see how many lines we had. So I was really excited and taken back when I saw that I was getting married. to my love of my life, the whole episode. I really enjoyed it all. You ask about my dresses. Well, back in those days, it sounds like the dark ages, but it was early 2000. Plus-sized women didn't
肯·惠廷汉姆，非常感谢你过来。嗨，肯。嘿，嘿，谢谢你们邀请我。见到你们真是太好了。太可爱了。我想到我们在节目中度过的所有美好时光，我已经很久没见到你们了，看到你们的脸真是太神奇了。
have a lot of choices. We either looked like the grandmother or the great-grandmother or the bride. There were not a lot of choices to be made for heavyset brides. And so I was just glad that I had a dress that looked pretty and was pretty comfortable. I have to give a shout out to wardrobe. They really, really took care of me. Every time I had to go to the restroom or anything, you know, they were right there to help me out with everything. But yeah, back in those days, I didn't have a lot of choices. And so I just wanted to make sure that my arms were covered. I have a thing about my arm showing on camera and in public. As far as the dress was concerned, yeah, I was happy with it. It was fairly comfortable. And like I said, Wardrow really kept me. They were right there every
我们看起来还是一样，对吧，肯？完全一样。也许有点，嗯，也许有点年轻，我说。哦，好吧。那也是我会说的。是的。好吧，肯，我们总是喜欢先问我们的嘉宾一点关于他们是如何在《办公室》得到这份工作的问题。
second of the moment. Aw, I thought she looked gorgeous in this episode. She looked so beautiful. That is the first time I've heard Phyllis's voice in a while. And Jenna, it just, it really made me tear up when I listened to it the first time when she sent them over. Yeah. She just, you can just hear Phyllis's just pure, she's just a pure soul. You know what I mean? And you just hear it when she talks. Do you know what one of my favorite parts of that audio clip was, Ange, was that she referred to herself as Phyllis Lapin Vance of Vance refrigeration. I know. She added it to the end. I know. I love it. Well, that was so fun to hear Phyllis.
你能告诉我们你是怎么认识格雷格的，以及你是怎么成为节目的一部分的吗？当然。我接到了经纪人的电话，他说他们要在美国重拍《办公室》。NBC 要做《办公室》。我已经是英国版的忠实粉丝了。我说，当然，我会去面试。所以他们寄给我，他们实际上寄给了我 DVD。
and she sent in several audio clips, you guys. So we're going to hear from her throughout this episode. Oh, and she sent in some good stuff. Yeah. Fast fact number three is Ken Whittingham, the director of this episode, joined us for an interview. Ken directed several episodes of the office, and we just loved him. The cast loved Ken. And Sam plays interview.
我并没有抱太大希望。我说，哦，伙计，我希望他们不要错过这些东西，因为它是一部如此精彩的节目。我看了它，我就想，哇，这真的很好。所以我去面试了，我见了特里·温伯格和格雷格·丹尼尔斯，我们谈论了它。我们谈论了美国是否准备好迎接这种类型的节目。我们真的广泛地谈论了它，你知道，如果美国会理解它的话。我非常乐观，说我认为美国准备好迎接一些不同的、新的东西了。
Ken Whittingham, thank you so much for stopping by. Hi, Ken. Hey, hey, thank you for having me. It is so nice to see you. Just so lovely. I think about all the great times we had on the show, and I've seen you guys in so long, and it's so, so amazing to see your faces.
这就是我们见面的方式。我们见面，我想是在我们，就在赛季开始之前，是的。所以他们已经拍了试播集。嗯哼。然后他们正在为该系列寻找导演。正确。正确。哇。
We look just the same, right, Ken? Exactly the same. Maybe a little, well, maybe a little younger, I said. Oh, okay. That's what I would have said as well. Yes. Well, Ken, we always like to start by asking our guests a little bit about how they got their job on the office.
是的。是的。我绝对可以看到格雷格在享受那次谈话，你知道，有点像谈论节目以及它将如何冲击美国，以及美国将如何对此做出反应。就像那是所有，你知道，他非常乐于进行那种谈话。是的。我们谈了很长时间。基本上我们谈论的就是这些，因为我提到了，我记得我提到了另一部在美国不太成功的节目。
Can you tell us how you met Greg and how you came to be a part of the show? Sure. I got a call for my agent and he said they're going to redo the office in America. NBC's going to do the office. And I was already a big fan of the British version. I said, sure, I'll go for the interview. And so they sent me, they actually sent me the DVD.
我想它叫《绝对精彩》。哦，你知道。他们在美国尝试过。很有趣，因为我走上了我真的不想走的路。我说，是的，就像那个节目，《绝对精彩》。他们说，哦，在你多说之前，我们也做了那个节目。我们制作了这个节目。不是格雷格，是杰瑞·温伯格。
And I didn't have a lot of hope for it. I said, oh, man, I hope they don't miss this stuff because it was such a brilliant show. And I watched it, and I was like, wow, this is really good. So I went in for the interview, and I met with Terry Weinberg and Greg Daniels, and we talked about it. And we talked about if America was ready for this type of show. And we really talked extensively about it, you know, if America was going to get it. And I was very optimistic and saying that I think America is ready for something different, something new.
所以他们说，好吧，你喜欢那个节目的什么。我说，嗯，我说，我认为每个人，这是真的，我认为每个人看起来都太漂亮了。每个人都长得很好看，这感觉不真实，你知道。肯，你执导了《办公室》的很多集，其中两集是外景拍摄。你有迈克尔的生日，是在溜冰场，现在是菲利斯的婚礼。让我们旅行并进行外景拍摄是什么感觉？太棒了。太棒了，移动，在外面，因为有时《办公室》会让人感到有点幽闭恐惧，而且非常安全。你知道，移动到外面并进行外景拍摄的挑战仍然是给它那种，
And that's how we met. We met, I guess it was right before we, right before the season started, yeah. So they had done the pilot. Mm-hmm. And then they were looking for directors for the series. Correct. Correct. Wow.
那种斯克兰顿的感觉，你知道，或者除了 Studio City 以外的某个地方。是的。所以，你知道，所以我们不想看到棕榈树之类的。所以那是一个真正的挑战。所以我们在准备期间，我们真的做了大量的准备，以确保它看起来有点像斯克兰顿或其他地方，某个不显眼的地方。所以那很有趣。而且能进入新的空间并尝试不同的东西，有点打开节目，这很有趣。
Yeah. Yeah. I can definitely see Greg eating up that conversation, you know, sort of like talking about the show and how it's going to hit America and how America is going to react to it. Like that's all sort of like he's so open to those kind of conversations, you know? Yeah. We talked a long time about it. That's basically all we talked about because I referenced, I remember referencing another show that really didn't work that well in America.
我一直很喜欢我做的任何节目去外面，稍微进入世界。我认为人们没有意识到的是一集的准备过程。你会有多长时间准备一集？因为我们说过我们拍摄一周。但你在拍摄前的准备时间有多长？我们的准备，相信那个节目是四天。就是这样。移动整个节目并不多。
I think it was called Absolutely Fabulous. Oh, you know. They tried it in America. And it was funny because I was going down this road that I really didn't want to go. I said, yeah, just like the show, absolutely fabulous. They said, oh, before you say too much, we did that show also. We produced this show. It wasn't Greg, it was Jerry Weinberg.
不。不。然后你不喜欢坐在一辆小货车里看外景吗，就像你们一群人挤在一辆货车里？我喜欢。我对你们装车离开片场有这样的记忆，我们就像，他们去哪儿了？是的，那真的会是第一天，因为他们会做，他们会锁定几个，就像外景部门会锁定几个选项，我们会有。然后我会去那些选项，导演和制片人，我们会去那些外景地。可能是两三个不同的地方，然后我们会在那时做出决定，这完全是
So they said, well, what did you like about that? that show. I said, well, I said, I think everybody, which was true, I think everybody looked too pretty. Everybody was just really good looking and it just didn't feel real, you know. Ken, you directed a lot of episodes on the office and two were on location. You had Michael's birthday that was at the ice skating rink and now Phyllis's wedding. What was it like having us travel and be on location? It was great. It was great moving, being outside because sometimes the office can get a little claustrophobic and it's very safe. you know, the challenge to moving outside and going on location is still give it that,
关于它是否可以拍摄，你知道，只是背景和外景地的可达性。我们能得到它吗？我们可以轻松地装载摄像机并轻松卸载吗？所以有很多事情我们需要意识到或有意识。所以是的，那基本上会在那个准备日，那将是我们做的第一件事，就是出去并尝试锁定外景地，因为获得使用特定外景地的许可证需要几天时间。现在，你更喜欢在办公室牛棚内拍摄还是在外面拍摄？我真的没有偏好。我真的没有偏好，因为，你知道，剧本写得太好了。
that feel of Scranton, you know, or someplace other than Studio City. Yeah. So, you know, so we didn't want to see palm trees and that. So that was a real challenge. And so during prep, we really prepped heavily to make sure that it looked somewhat like Scranton or somewhere else, some place nondescript. So that was fun. And it was just fun to be in new spaces and try different things and kind of open the show up.
我的意思是，我昨天真的在读“菲利斯的婚礼”，再次读剧本。它写得太好了。我的意思是，它写得太好了。所以无论它在哪里，都没关系，因为文字真的驱动了喜剧，你知道。所以它是，这就是它的伟大之处，你知道。所以这一集中有所有这些伟大的小时刻。你知道，你有帕姆和罗伊跳舞，然后你有安吉拉和德怀特在外面，然后所有这些小片段，比如迈克尔的头在窗户里上下晃动。弄清楚那些小时刻会在哪里发生是什么感觉？
I'm always a big fan of any show that I do going outside and getting into the world a little bit. I think something people don't realize is the prep process for an episode. How long would you get to prep an episode? Because we've said we shoot for a week. But how long was your prep before shooting? Our prep was, believe that show was four days. That's it. That's not a lot to move a whole show.
以及你是如何捕捉它们的？嗯，我会做的是我有点，我是一个超级准备者。所以我会有，我会，我有点，我想对于这一集，我制作了一个镜头列表以及我们进入的顺序。所以我所做的是我有点跳房子。我会在别处设置一些东西，然后拿一个摄像机去拍别的东西。所以我总是稍微领先一点，以便能够捕捉到所有这些东西。因为那一集，我们有，我几天前刚看了一下，
No. No. And then don't you like ride around in a little van and look at locations, like a bunch of you all cramped in a van? I do. I have such a memory of you guys loading up and leaving set and we're like, where do they go? Yeah, it would really be the first day because they would do, they would lock down a couple, like the locations department would lock down a couple's options that we would have. And then I would go to those options, the director and producers, we would go to those locations. might be two or three different places and then we would make the decision then and it was all
有很多时刻没有在这一集中，我们拍了，你知道。所以，而且我认为通常我们会，什么，超过六、七、八分钟，通常在每一集。所以我们会拍的比我们真正需要的更多。但我会保持领先，只是试着把所有东西都拍进去，你知道，而且它非常，非常有计划。而且，我的意思是，有些事情，你知道，在当天，我们会做一些没有计划的事情，比如当阿尔叔叔
about whether or not it was shootable you know just backgrounds and and just accessibility to the location could we get it could we load cameras in easily and load out easily so there are a lot of things we had to we had to be aware of or be conscious of so yeah that would be basically on that prep day that would be the first thing we would do is go out and try to lock down the locations because it would take a few days to get a permit to use specific locations. Now, did you have a preference of shooting the episodes inside the office bullpen or outside? I didn't really have a preference. I didn't really have a preference because, you know, the writing was just so good.
走到外面时，我想最初他应该坐在长椅上，我们走到外面，那是晚上，我说，如果他走进街道，他是绿色的，然后他逆着交通方向走，汽车开过来，汽车真的在按喇叭，所有东西，所以我们使用了
I mean, literally I was reading Phyllis's wedding yesterday, reading the script again. And it was just so, I don't know, it's just written so well. I mean, it's just written so well. So it was just like wherever it was, it didn't matter because the words really kind of drove the comedy, you know. So it was, that's what was great about it, you know. So there were all of these great little moments in this episode. You know, you had the Pam and Roy dancing and then you had Angela and Dwight outside and then all these little vignettes like Michael's head bobbing up in the window. And what was that like to sort of figure out where those little moments would happen?
所有那些东西，所以没有一个是按剧本写的。我们只是有点想出了那个，你知道，在我们的脑海里，你知道。这创造了更多的紧张感，是的。而不是他只是坐在长椅上。那真是个好主意。你真的很担心他会晚上在某个地方徘徊。对。完全正确。是的。我想在这一集中你看到了灯光转动。
and how you captured them? Well, what I would do is I kind of, I'm a super prepper. So I would, I would, I kind of, I think for this episode, I've made a shot list and the order in which we would go on and go in. So what I would do is I kind of hopscotch. I was set up something somewhere else and then take a camera and go shoot something else. And so I was always staying ahead a little bit to be able to capture all that stuff. Because that episode, we had, I was just looking at it a few days ago,
是的。所以我们计时了，所有东西。所以那真的很有趣。我很高兴它进入了剪辑。是的。好吧，肯，看着安吉拉·马丁到达并看到德怀特，他们进行了简短的交流，我感到非常高兴。但那有点就是这样。然后我们就得去教堂了。我记得和你玩过关于。我们如何然后就像我们感觉向左打破，不要向左徘徊等等所有那种东西，对吧？我只记得你让我们稍微玩了一下，这太荒谬和可笑了，对吧？我们玩得很开心，那很有趣，那真的很有趣，因为我只是，我真的想在你们两个之间创造尴尬，你知道，因为我知道你们应该
there were so many moments that weren't in the episode that we shot, you know. And so, and I think typically we would be, what, six, seven, eight minutes over, typically on every episode. So we would shoot more than a lot than we, more than we really needed. But I would just stay ahead and just try to get it all in, you know, and just, and it was very, very planned. And, I mean, some things, you know, on the day, we would do things that weren't planned, like when Uncle Al
稍后去见丹尼斯，是的，然后所以他们必须是这个小，你知道，这个紧张局势，特别是当他给你那个赞美时，你知道。所以我认为那有点，你知道，在我的脑海里，那有点密封了它。就像，你对他变得更有吸引力了。所以你更容易拒绝这个家伙。谁对她来说太完美了。是的。那是一个跑步者，伙计们，没有进入这一集。
went outside, I think initially he was supposed to be sitting on a bench and we got outside and it was nighttime, I said, if he walked into the street he was green and then he went the opposite way against traffic and cars came down and literally cars were honking and everything so we used
菲利斯让安吉拉坐在一个叫丹尼斯的家伙旁边。她有点试图在招待会上撮合她。丹尼斯是一名兽医。他喜欢猫和耶稣。我的意思是，她选择德怀特是因为他告诉她她看起来像英国女王。完全正确。太搞笑了。我知道。
all that stuff and so no of that was scripted. We just kind of came up with that, you know, on the top of our heads, you know. That created so much more tension yes. Then him just sitting on a bench. That was such a good idea. You were really worried he was just going to be wandering off somewhere in the night. Right. Exactly. Yeah. I think in the episode you see the light turn.
所以，是的。我希望丹尼斯的一些东西能进入，但我猜我们，再次，我们没有时间。但这里面有很多好东西，你知道？是的，是的。我们甚至有，我想是，我不认为它也进入了这一集。我们有迈克尔去。有一把椅子有点，你知道那些椅子是。
Yeah. So we timed it and everything. So that was really a lot of fun. I'm glad that made it into the cut. Yeah. Well, Ken, I got so tickled just watching that moment when Angela Martin arrives and sees Dwight and they have that brief exchange. But that was kind of it. And then then we had to go into the church. And I remember playing with you about. how do we then like we feel like break left don't linger left and all of that kind of stuff right and I just remember you letting us play a little bit with that and it was so absurd and ridiculous right we just had so much fun that was fun that was a lot of fun because I just I really wanted to create the awkwardness between the two of you you know because I knew that you were supposed
不能走楼梯的人。是的。那是在上下。我们也没有使用任何这些。我们只是，它只是太愚蠢了。这就是在外景拍摄的美妙之处，你有这些空间，你得到这些想法，你可以做一些根本没有按剧本写的事情。你知道，所以那是，那是外景拍摄的伟大之处之一。好吧，有很多非常好的删减场景。
to be meeting Dennis later on yes and then so they had to be this little you know this tension in, especially when he gave you that compliment, you know. And so I think that kind of, you know, I don't know, in my mind, that kind of sealed it. Like, you just became more attractive to him. And so it was easier for you to kind of blow this other guy off. Who was so perfect for her. Yeah. That's a runner, you guys, that didn't make it in the episode.
所以对于有 DVD 的人，你必须去看看肯拍的所有其他东西。人们总是想知道。知道这一集的导演是否也必须拍摄闪回时刻。你必须拍摄那个小迈克尔在他妈妈和杰夫的婚礼上的时刻吗？是的。是的，那很有趣。那很有趣，因为我们知道它需要看起来有点复古，所以，我们有点移动摄像机，就像它是旧 VHS 摄像机，你知道，然后我们，当然，在后期，我们有点修补了它。但它真的很有趣。它很有趣。
Phyllis sits Angela next to this guy named Dennis. She kind of tries to set her up at the, you know, at the reception. And Dennis is a vet. He loves cats and Jesus. I mean, she chooses Dwight because he told her she looks like the queen of England. Exactly. So funny. I know.
我们拍了它，我们只是希望它看起来很棒
So, yeah. I wish some of the stuff would have made it in, the stuff from Dennis. But I guess we, again, we just didn't have time. But there's so much good stuff in here, you know? Yeah, yeah. And we even had, I think it was, I don't think it made it into the episode as well. We had Mike going. There was a chair that kind of, you know, those chairs were.
看起来复古，你知道，看起来更老。所以我认为我们实现了它。它看起来棒极了。你是在第一天做那个，以便迈克尔以后可以看它吗？还是你把它 CGI 到电视上？是的，我们做了。我们在第一天拍了它，然后我们回放了它。
People who can't walk upstairs. Yes. That was going up and down. We didn't use any of that either. We were just, it was just so much stupid. And that's the beauty about being on location is that you have these spaces that and you get these ideas that you can just do stuff that's not scripted at all. You know, so that's, that's one of the great things about being on location. Well, there are a lot of really great deleted scenes.
我相信这就是我们做的方式。好吧，这一集有太多非常棒的大设置。有没有哪个时刻是最具挑战性拍摄的，或者对你来说非常有趣。只是这些场景之一，只是击中了你。我不认为真的有什么太具挑战性的。有一个场景真的很难通过。我会说那有点挑战性，因为我们无法停止大笑。
So for people that have the DVDs, you have to go see all the other stuff that Ken shot. People always want to know. know if the directors of episodes also have to shoot the flashback moments. Did you have to shoot that moment with little Michael at his mom's wedding to Jeff? Yeah. Yeah, that was a lot of fun. That was a lot of fun because we knew that it needed to look a little vintage and so, and we kind of moved the camera like it was old VHS camera, you know, and then we, of course, in post, we kind of doctored it. But it was really fun. It was a lot of fun. and we shot it and we just hope that it would look great
那就是当迈克尔进去检查菲利斯看看她怎么样时。然后他说，你知道，你放屁了吗？你打破了风吗？是的，是的，是的。你知道关于那个有趣的事情是，那是一个放入剧本的笑话，并没有真正打算留在剧本里。真的吗？是的，那从来没有真正打算。它只是一个笑话，如果发生这种情况不会很有趣吗，然后它就活了下来。我想卡罗琳告诉我，卡罗琳·威廉姆斯，这一集的编剧。所以它就有点留下了，我们只是，拍了它，迈克尔，你知道史蒂夫太好了，他无法停止大笑，我的意思是，他无法停止，我从来没见过他那样崩溃，我们所有人都只是，我们花了一个小时才得到
and look vintage, you know, looked older. So I think we achieved it. It looked fantastic. Do you do that on the first day so that then Michael can watch it later? Or do you like CGI it onto the TV? Yes, we did. We shot it on the first day and then we played it back.
因为我们无法停止大笑，好吧，你知道菲利斯总是能够有这样真诚的表情，你知道，每当你不得不对她刻薄或者只是对她有一些随机的台词时，她会用这些甜美的眼睛看着你，所以我可以看到史蒂夫无法通过它。就像，那真的很刺鼻。她只是，嗯。对。然后他开始摆弄她的头发。
I believe that's how we did it. Well, there were so many just fantastic big setups for this episode. Was there any moment that was the most challenging to shoot or like something really funny for you. Just one of these scenes that just hit you. I don't think that there was really anything too challenging. There was one scene that was really hard to get through. I would say that was kind of challenging because we could not stop laughing.
哦，天哪。这就像，好吧，你得走了。我觉得她整个内心独白只是六周假期，六周假期。对。是的，因为那是她要得到的。对，完全正确。这就是她要度过它的方式。是的，是的。
And that's when Michael went into the check on Phyllis to see how she was doing. And then he said, you know, did you pass gas? Did you break the wind? Yeah, yeah, yeah. And you know, the funny thing about that is that was a joke that was put into the script that wasn't really supposed to stay in the script. Really? Yeah, that was never really supposed to. It was just like a joke that wouldn't it be funny if this happened, and then it just lived. And I guess Carolyn was telling me that Carolyn Williams, the writer of the episode. So it just kind of stayed, and we just, shot it and Michael you know Steve was so good he could not stop laughing and I mean he could not stop and I've never seen him break like that and we all were just like it took us about an hour to get
就在那时，迈克尔去查看菲利斯的情况，看看她怎么样了。然后他说，你知道，你放屁了吗？你排气了吗？对，对，对。你知道，有趣的是，那是一个被写进剧本里，本不该留在剧本里的笑话。真的吗？是的，它本来不该留下的。那只是一个“如果发生这种事会不会很有趣”的笑话，结果它就留下来了。我想是卡罗琳告诉我的，卡罗琳·威廉姆斯，这一集的编剧。所以它就留下了，我们把它拍了下来，迈克尔，你知道史蒂夫太棒了，他笑得停不下来，我是说他根本停不下来，我从来没见过他那样笑场，我们所有人都觉得花了大约一个小时才拍完
because we could not stop laughing well you know Phyllis always was able to have such this earnest expression you know and whenever you had to be mean to her or just like have some random line towards her and she would look at you with these sweet eyes so So I can see Steve not being able to get through it. Being like, that is really pungent. She's just like, hmm. Right. And then he started messing around with her hair.
因为我们笑得停不下来。嗯，你知道菲利斯总是能表现出那种真诚的表情，你知道，每当你不得不对她刻薄，或者对她说些莫名其妙的话时，她就会用那双甜美的眼睛看着你。所以我能理解史蒂夫为什么演不下去。就像说，那真的很刺鼻。她只是，嗯。对。然后他开始摆弄她的头发。
Oh, my God. It's just like, okay, you got to go. I feel like her whole interior monologue was just six weeks vacation, six weeks vacation. Right. Yeah, because that's what she was going to get. Right, exactly. That's how she's going to get through it. Yeah, yeah.
天哪。就像是，好吧，你得走了。我觉得她整个内心的独白就是六周假期，六周假期。对。是的，因为那就是她将要得到的。对，没错。那就是她熬过这一关的方式。对，对。
With Bob Vance. Yeah, exactly. And I loved in the wedding. I loved so much that they were like, do you Phyllis take Bob Vance of Vance refrigeration? Yeah. Like his, you're taking the whole thing. That's what was so great about that. I think it was in the merger when she told when she told Rashida, you know, you don't know who Bob Vance is, you know, you got a lot to learn, Missy.
和鲍勃·万斯。没错，正是如此。我很喜欢婚礼上的那个桥段。我特别喜欢他们说：“菲利斯，你愿意嫁给万斯制冷的鲍勃·万斯吗？”是的，就像是，你连带着整个公司一起嫁了。这就是那个桥段最棒的地方。我想是在公司合并的时候，她告诉拉什达，你知道，你不知道鲍勃·万斯是谁，你知道，你还有很多东西要学，小姑娘。
And that's what was so funny about it because Bob Vance is a big deal in that town. You know, so he was all up, you know, it's all about Bob Vance Refrigeration. Everybody knew him. Well, Phyllis is now the first lady of Vance Refrigeration. I mean, she's going to play the part. Right, right. I'm sure she's going to have to go to, I don't know, is there ribbon cuttings involved in Vance Refrigeration when they install like everything in a new restaurant or something?
这就是它最有趣的地方，因为鲍勃·万斯在那个镇上是个大人物。你知道，所以他总是，你知道，一切都围绕着万斯制冷。每个人都认识他。好吧，菲利斯现在是万斯制冷的第一夫人了。我的意思是，她得扮演好这个角色。对，对。我敢肯定她得去，我不知道，万斯制冷在安装新餐厅设备什么的的时候，会有剪彩仪式吗？
Yeah, I feel like there's a shopping mall where there's little like kind of stars like the Hollywood Walk of Fame and Bob Vance gets one. And they all go to downtown Scranton. That's right. And then there has to be a commercial and she has to be in the commercial for Bob Van. Oh, oh, I wish we'd film that. Why did we never shoot that? Oh, Ken, that is brilliant. Oh, that's the content we're missing. Ken, so we said before that you've directed nine episodes of The Office. Do you have a favorite? Can you pick a favorite? Oh, that's hard. You know what? It's a toss-up of I think between Phyllis's wedding, actually, and health care. Hot dog fingers.
是的，我觉得应该有个购物中心，那里有像好莱坞星光大道那样的小星星，鲍勃·万斯就有一颗。他们都去了斯克兰顿市中心。没错。然后还得有个广告，她必须出现在鲍勃·万斯的广告里。哦，哦，我真希望我们拍了那个。为什么我们从来没拍过？哦，肯，那太天才了。哦，那就是我们错失的内容。肯，我们之前说过你执导了九集《办公室》。你有最喜欢的一集吗？你能选出一集最喜欢的吗？哦，那很难。你知道吗？我觉得在菲利斯的婚礼和医疗保健之间，其实很难抉择。热狗手指。
Yeah, yeah. Health care. Oh, my God. I can watch that over and over and over. I mean, it was so great about it. We were just, I think we shot, we definitely shot it within the first six. But we were all trying to figure out what the show was about and, you know, and trying to make it our own and trying different stuff.
是啊，是啊。医疗保健。天哪。我可以一遍又一遍地看那一集。我的意思是，它太棒了。我们当时，我想我们拍了，我们肯定是在前六集里拍的。但我们都在试图弄清楚这部剧到底是什么，你知道，试图把它变成我们自己的东西，尝试不同的东西。
and we were all getting used to each other. It was just great. I loved, I loved doing the, you know, being in the beginning of it. Because it was, did we shoot it? Was that the third episode we shot? Do you remember? You know, I think we shot that season a little out of order. So it might have been like it was the fifth episode we shot, but it was the third episode that aired.
我们都在适应彼此。那真是太棒了。我喜欢，我喜欢做，你知道，参与它的开端。因为那是，我们拍了吗？那是我们拍的第三集吗？你记得吗？你知道，我觉得那一季我们拍得有点乱。所以它可能是我们拍的第五集，但它是播出的第三集。
It aired. That's what it was. Those were the early days. That was when we only got six and then they sent us home. Yeah, exactly. So that was a really magical time. It really, really was. And everybody was so unsure about it.
它播出了。就是那样。那是早期。那是我们只拍了六集，然后他们就让我们回家的时候。是的，没错。所以那是一段非常神奇的时光。真的，真的是。每个人对它都非常不确定。
And I just remember walking away and just feeling so good about it. You know, just feeling so like, wow, that was really fun and different and great. And the cast was, everybody was perfect. And I remember my agent saying the next season came around. And I saw all the attention that it was getting. from from from iTunes and and so I made sure I called my agent and said look you got to get me back on that show you know that show is you know because I think it was up in the end we didn't know if we were coming back or not yeah yeah I said if they come back I got to be I want to be
我只记得离开时感觉非常好。你知道，就是感觉，哇，那真的很有趣，与众不同，而且很棒。演员阵容，每个人都很完美。我记得下一季到来时，我的经纪人说。我看到了它从iTunes上获得的所有关注。所以我一定要打电话给我的经纪人说，听着，你得让我回到那个节目，你知道那个节目，你知道，因为我想当时在最后，我们不知道我们是否会回来。是啊，是啊，我说如果他们回来，我一定要，我想参与那个节目。
involved in that show so so luckily the college kids got us you know got to put on that you know the college kids and now the middle schoolers exactly they're keeping us going You know, it's funny is that I still, I really lead with that, when people ask me with shows, if I explain to somebody that I'm a director, and they say, what shows have you done? Anything I've known? And I goes, well, a little show called The Office. You know, I bragging about it.
参与那个节目，所以幸运的是，大学生们让我们，你知道，让我们继续，你知道，大学生们，现在还有初中生们，没错，他们让我们继续前进。你知道，有趣的是，我仍然，我真的以此为荣，当人们问我关于节目时，如果我向某人解释我是导演，他们说，你做过什么节目？有什么我认识的吗？我说，嗯，一个叫《办公室》的小节目。你知道，我在吹嘘它。
They're like, what? So I get a lot of props for that. I'm just so appreciative to be a part of that show. It's just such a, such a great show. And it's a kind of show that you can just still watch over and over and over. And still, because there's all these little subtleties and, and just moments, you know, like we talked about Michael jumping up and down in the, you know, in the, you know, the window and looks like when, you know, when Pam and Roy were dancing and then, you know, Pam and Roy and then, you know, you know, you're just, you know, you're just really sweet, sweet moments. And you just, you know, you just cherish those, those great moments. Ken, this was so lovely. Thank you so much.
他们会说，什么？所以我因此得到了很多赞誉。我非常感激能成为那个节目的一部分。它真是，真是太棒了。而且它是那种你可以一遍又一遍观看的节目。而且仍然，因为里面有所有这些微妙之处，还有，还有那些时刻，你知道，就像我们谈到的迈克尔在窗户里跳上跳下，你知道，当帕姆和罗伊在跳舞时，然后，你知道，帕姆和罗伊，然后，你知道，你知道，你只是，你知道，你只是非常甜蜜，甜蜜的时刻。你只是，你知道，你只是珍惜那些，那些伟大的时刻。肯，这太可爱了。非常感谢。
And what are you up to now? Well, now I know that you directed some Bless Your Mess, which is the show that replaced my show. I know, I know. But if it makes you feel in bed, we got canceled too. Oh, well, I mean, I'm not saying I feel better. But yeah, I'm just, I'm doing a new show with Jamie Fox on for Netflix. which is called,
你现在在忙什么？嗯，现在我知道你执导了一些《祝福你的混乱》，那是取代我节目的那个节目。我知道，我知道。但如果这能让你感觉好点的话，我们也取消了。哦，好吧，我的意思是，我不是说我感觉好些了。但是是的，我只是，我正在和杰米·福克斯一起为Netflix做一个新节目。叫作，
Dad, Stop Embarrassing Me. It's loosely based on him and his daughter's relationship. And then in the fall, late fall now, I think after the election, I'm doing a show for NBC with Keenan Thompson, as called Wake Up with Keenan. And it's Keenan Thompson and Don Johnson and Maya Rudolph is a, well, Maya Rudolph was his wife. but it passed away so I think so that's basically the storyline is he has a he has a morning show
《爸爸，别让我尴尬》。它大致基于他和女儿的关系。然后到了秋天，现在是深秋了，我想在选举之后，我正在为NBC做一个节目，和基南·汤普森一起，叫作《与基南醒来》。那是基南·汤普森和唐·约翰逊，还有玛雅·鲁道夫是，嗯，玛雅·鲁道夫曾是他的妻子。但去世了，所以我认为，所以这基本上是故事情节，他有一个早间节目，
and then he's taking care of two kids and Don Johnson is his father-in-law oh my gosh yeah so so that's it seems like it's going to be a lot of fun we're really looking forward to that well Ken you were so beloved by the office cast we we have talked to so many of the cast members in doing this podcast. We reach out to people, Phyllis sent us in audio clips. And she was like, oh, and it was Ken Whittingham. And we always loved it when Ken was there. And just know that you have so much love for you from our cast. And Jenna and I would love for you to come back. So, so yeah, come on back. Anytime. I love it. Anytime. I love you guys. And I miss you guys. And I even still think about you, Jenna. I go, when I'm in Laguna, I go, did Jenna move down here? I want to see her around here.
然后他在照顾两个孩子，唐·约翰逊是他的岳父。哦，天哪。是啊，所以看起来会很有趣，我们真的很期待那个。好吧，肯，你深受《办公室》演员们的喜爱，我们在做这个播客时和这么多演员谈过。我们联系人们，菲利斯给我们发了音频片段。她说，哦，那是肯·惠廷汉姆。我们总是很喜欢肯在的时候。只要知道我们的演员对你有这么多爱。珍娜和我都希望你能回来。所以，所以是的，回来吧。随时。我喜欢。随时。我爱你们。我好想你们。我甚至还在想你，珍娜。我说，当我在拉古纳时，我说，珍娜搬到这里了吗？我想在这里见到她。
Well, we would spend how much time just talking about Laguna, moving to Laguna, looking at the house in the Lugna. I have this dream of like one day moving to a beach house, cashing out of L.A. Right. Yeah, you are talking up Laguna. You know, it's really funny because right after I get off, when I'm done with this, I'm going down there. My wife's down there now. So I'll be there. Oh, man.
嗯，我们会花多少时间谈论拉古纳，搬到拉古纳，看拉古纳的房子。我有一个梦想，就是有一天搬到海滨别墅，从洛杉矶套现。对。是的，你在谈论拉古纳。你知道，这真的很有趣，因为我一结束，当我做完这个，我就要下去了。我妻子现在就在那儿。所以我会在那儿。哦，天哪。
Oh, well, all of our love to you. Thanks for coming on today. Thanks, Ken. Thanks, my mom. Bye. Bye. Bye. This is an ad by Better Help. You know, it feels like nowadays there's advice for just about everything. It's like, do you write in your journal, do you do, I don't know, cleanses or the cold plunge or, you know, what helps you get through the day? What helps you get through stressful moments? For me, it's talking it out. Mm-hmm. Well, there can be a lot of information overload about mental.
哦，好吧，我们所有的爱都给你。谢谢你今天来。谢谢，肯。谢谢，我的妈妈。再见。再见。再见。这是Better Help的一则广告。你知道，感觉现在几乎每件事都有建议。就像，你写日记吗，你做，我不知道，排毒，或者冷水浴，或者，你知道，什么能帮你度过这一天？什么能帮你度过压力时刻？对我来说，是说出来。嗯。嗯。好吧，关于心理健康和健康的信息可能太多了，知道什么是真的，这些天该采取什么行动可能是一种挣扎。所以你可能会考虑使用一个值得信赖的资源，并通过BetterHelp与真人治疗师交谈。它在应用商店的评分为4.9分（满分5分），基于超过170万条客户评论。作为世界上最大的在线治疗提供商，BetterHelp可以提供接触具有各种专业知识的心理健康专业人员的机会。和BetterHelp说出来。我们的听众在BetterHelp.com/officeladies首次购买可享受10%的折扣。那是BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。
mental health and wellness, and it can be a struggle to know what's true and what actions to take these days. So you might think about using a trusted resource and talking to live therapists through BetterHelp. It has an app store rating of 4.9 out of 5 based on over 1.7 million client reviews. As the largest online therapy provider in the world, BetterHelp can provide access to mental health professionals with a diverse variety of expertise. Talk it out with BetterHelp. Our listeners get 10% off their first month at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's BetterHelp, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies.
（注：此段为BetterHelp广告，已翻译）
Hi, I'm PJ Vote, and I want to tell you about my podcast search engine. We try to make sense of the world, one question at a time. No question too big, no question too small. We will even answer your questions if you send them in. Stuff like, what happens when a cemetery goes out of business? What should we do about teens using AI to do their homework? Who buys luggage at the airport luggage store? Follow and listen to Search Engine, in partnership with Odyssey,
嗨，我是PJ·沃特，我想告诉你关于我的播客《搜索引擎》。我们试图理解这个世界，一次一个问题。没有太大的问题，没有太小的问题。如果你把问题发给我们，我们甚至会回答你的问题。比如，当墓地倒闭时会发生什么？我们应该如何处理青少年使用人工智能做作业？谁在机场行李店买行李？关注并收听《搜索引擎》，与Odyssey合作，
wherever you get your podcasts. Get to Toronto's main venues like Budweiser Stage and the new Roger Stadium with Go Transit. Thanks to Go Transit's special online e-ticket fairs, a $10 one-day weekend pass offers unlimited travel on any weekend day or holiday anywhere along the Go network. And the weekday group passes offer the same weekday travel flexibility across the network, starting at $30 for two people and up to $60 for a group of five.
无论你在哪里获取播客。通过Go Transit前往多伦多的主要场馆，如百威舞台和新的罗杰斯体育场。感谢Go Transit的特别在线电子票价，10美元的一日周末通票提供在任何周末或节假日，在Go网络沿线的任何地方无限次旅行。工作日团体通票在整个网络提供同样的工作日旅行灵活性，两人起价30美元，五人团体最高60美元。
Buy your online go pass ahead of the show at go-transit.com slash tickets. How fun was that? He's the best. Well, let's get into this episode, Jenna. We start with a cold open. It's a classic Jim prank. You know, Jim says he has to reboot his computer and it makes this chiming noise. and then he offers Dwight an altoyd.
在演出前在go-transit.com/tickets购买你的在线Go通票。那有多有趣？他是最棒的。好吧，让我们进入这一集，珍娜。我们从冷开场开始。这是一个经典的吉姆恶作剧。你知道，吉姆说他必须重启电脑，它发出了这种叮当声。然后他给德怀特一个奥托伊德薄荷糖。
And then he keeps doing this over and over, sort of like that Pavlovian, you know, sort of experiment with Dwight. Yes. And Jim's prank works. Yeah. After several times of doing this, the ding goes off and Dwight immediately puts his hand out for a mint. And he doesn't know why. Yes. He's just doing it on reflex.
然后他一遍又一遍地这样做，有点像那个巴甫洛夫，你知道，那种对德怀特的实验。是的。吉姆的恶作剧奏效了。是的。在做了几次之后，叮当声响起，德怀特立刻伸出手要薄荷糖。他不知道为什么。是的。他只是出于反射。
Yes. So we got a lot of mail about this. Blakey, Emma, Kayla, Bethany, and Elise all wrote in to say, in the cold open of this episode, the scene is a montage of multiple days. Did John and Rain have to constantly change outfits just to get this one scene? Yes. They had a rack of clothes of all these different changes, and they would film go change, film go change, film go change. Yeah.
是的。所以我们收到了很多关于这个的邮件。布莱基、艾玛、凯拉、贝瑟尼和埃莉斯都写信说，在这一集的冷开场中，场景是多天的蒙太奇。约翰和雷恩是否必须不断更换服装才能拍完这一个场景？是的。他们有一排衣服，有所有这些不同的变化，他们会拍，去换，拍，去换，拍，去换。是啊。
Yeah. And all the while, wardrobe is keeping track. And Veda on set, she's like keeping track of when they're in what outfit so that they could just get it done. But guys, it wasn't just John and Rain. All the rest of us were in the background. Yes, anyone that the camera saw had to change as well. Well, I remember getting to work to shoot this cold open. And there were like seven outfits in my trailer, which never happened.
是的，而且一直以来，服装组都在跟踪。片场的维达，她就像在跟踪他们什么时候穿什么衣服，这样他们就能完成它。但是伙计们，不仅仅是约翰和雷恩。我们其余的人都在背景里。是的，摄像机看到的任何人都必须更换。嗯，我记得去上班拍这个冷开场。我的拖车里有七套衣服，这从来没发生过。
We would have one outfit. We would wear it every single day for five days. I mean, they washed it, guys. They washed it. Well, yeah, we wore the same thing every day. Yeah. But to walk in and like my little closet was totally full of all these clothes. I had to go back and look and be like, wait, what?
我们只有一套衣服。我们五天里每天都穿它。我的意思是，他们洗了它，伙计们。他们洗了它。嗯，是的，我们每天都穿同样的东西。是的。但是走进去，就像我的小衣柜里装满了所有这些衣服。我不得不回去看，就像，等等，什么？
Oh, yeah, it's the cold open with the dinging computer. That's a great catch. And then we just had this fun tidbit from Amanda Teague who said, My Psychology Professor used the cold open of this episode to teach us about the Pavlovian theory. Oh, my gosh. Well, last night I read up a lot about Pavlov. I'm not going to go into it. Oh, no.
哦，是的，这是电脑叮当声的冷开场。那是一个很棒的捕捉。然后我们刚刚从阿曼达·蒂格那里得到了这个有趣的花絮，她说，我的心理学教授用这一集的冷开场来教我们巴甫洛夫理论。哦，天哪。好吧，昨晚我读了很多关于巴甫洛夫的书。我不打算深入探讨它。哦，不。
Here's the first time I'm doing a deep dive and I'm like, you know what, you guys? It was fascinating. it's a whole podcast in itself. Well, now I'm intrigued. Okay, I will read one thing that I discovered, okay? You know what? It's a shallow dive. Give me a shallow dive.
这是我第一次深入研究，我想，你知道吗，你们？这太迷人了。它本身就是一个完整的播客。好吧，现在我很好奇。好吧，我会读我发现的一件事，好吗？你知道吗？这是一个浅层研究。给我一个浅层研究。
Pavlov studied a lot about conditioning and how we react to things. How we can have involuntary reactions to stress or pain are like the cues that Jim was doing to Dwight with the chime and then you get a treat. Okay. This is the part I found really fascinating. They began to study trans marginal inhibitions, the body's natural. response of shutting down when exposed to overwhelming stress or pain. I mean, I guess like going into shock? Yeah, yeah.
巴甫洛夫研究了很多关于条件反射以及我们如何对事物做出反应。我们如何对压力或疼痛产生非自愿反应，就像吉姆用叮当声对德怀特做的暗示，然后你得到奖励。好吧。这是我发现非常迷人的部分。他们开始研究跨边缘抑制，身体在暴露于压倒性压力或疼痛时的自然反应。我的意思是，我想就像休克一样？是啊，是啊。
Like when your body just shuts down. Research showed that different temperaments move through the responses at different times. I thought this was fascinating because you know something might happen traumatic in your life and you and the members of your family or your friends all experience it a little bit differently. Yeah. And you travel through stress and pain different. differently. Pavlov commented that the most basic inherited difference of people as they travel through stress and pain was how soon they reach the shutdown point and that people that are quick to shut down have a fundamentally different type of nervous system. Like on a cellular level, they have a different nervous system? I guess. This is why it needs a massive deep dive. Well, that's a shallow dive that's making me want to dive into the deep end. I'm going to start ordering more books. I haven't gotten my books yet about Jan Levinson Gould's name psychology people yet, but I'm waiting.
就像你的身体关闭了一样。研究表明，不同的气质在不同的时间经历反应。我觉得这很迷人，因为你知道生活中可能会发生创伤性的事情，你和你的家人或朋友成员都经历得有点不同。是的。而且你经历压力和疼痛的方式不同。巴甫洛夫评论说，人们在经历压力和疼痛时最基本的遗传差异是他们多快达到关闭点，而那些容易关闭的人拥有根本不同类型的神经系统。就像在细胞层面上，他们有不同的神经系统？我想是这样。这就是为什么它需要大规模的深入研究。好吧，那是一个让我想要潜入深水区的浅层研究。我开始订购更多的书了。我还没有收到关于简·莱文森·古尔德名字心理学的人的书，但我正在等。
You have a lot to read, lady. You're going to be very busy. All right. Well, should we move into the meat of this episode, the spam of this episode? You reminded me when you said that of like Michael, like, who wants my meat? Yes, let's get into the meat of this episode. We're at the church. Phyllis's wedding party is out on the steps being photographed. Michael is trying to squeeze himself into these pictures. The photographer does that great bit where he's like, you know what, just, just Phyllis and her parents. But then also the bridesmaids and also you two.
你有很多书要读，女士。你会很忙的。好吧。好吧，我们应该进入这一集的重点，这一集的肉吗？你说那个的时候让我想起了迈克尔，就像，谁想要我的肉？是的，让我们进入这一集的重点。我们在教堂。菲利斯的婚礼派对在台阶上被拍照。迈克尔正试图把自己挤进这些照片里。摄影师做了那个很棒的片段，他说，你知道吗，只是，只是菲利斯和她的父母。但还有伴娘，还有你们两个。
It's like basically everyone. Everyone but Michael. Well, people wrote in, Sydney Pappas, Henry Wengard, Tara S, James G, and Emily Lankham all want to know who played Phyllis's bride. maids, and family. Were they all actors? Were any of them her real family members, like Mindy's parents and Diwali? No, they were all actors. Her main sister that we see throughout the episode was played by Maylee Flanagan, and the photographer in the scene was played by John F. Schaefer. So those are just a couple of the guest stars. You know, Mayle Flanagan is a great improv sketch actress, and she performed with Wayne Wilderson and Nancy Wals before she was Nancy Correl.
就像基本上每个人。除了迈克尔以外的每个人。嗯，人们写信进来，悉尼·帕帕斯、亨利·温加德、塔拉·S、詹姆斯·G和艾米丽·兰卡姆都想知道谁扮演了菲利斯的伴娘和家人。他们都是演员吗？他们中有人是她真正的家人吗，比如明迪的父母和排灯节？不，他们都是演员。我们在整集中看到的她的主要姐妹由梅莉·弗拉纳根扮演，场景中的摄影师由约翰·F·谢弗扮演。所以这些只是几个客串明星。你知道，梅莉·弗拉纳根是一位很棒的即兴小品演员，她在成为南希·科雷尔之前曾与韦恩·威尔德森和南希·沃尔斯一起表演。
Oh, M.G. Well, next up, Michael explains that he is part of the wedding party because Phyllis has asked him to push her father down the aisle. So he's basically giving away the bride. And it's a big day for Phyllis, but it's also just a really big day for him. He's employer of the bride. Well, then Phyllis has a talking head explaining the reason why she asked Michael to be in the wedding. She said she is going to get a. six-week vacation. Yeah. A six-week honeymoon. And that's never been done. So she had her motives. She did. And she's going to pay for it.
哦，M.G.好吧，接下来，迈克尔解释说他是婚礼派对的一部分，因为菲利斯要求他推她父亲走过过道。所以他基本上是在送新娘出嫁。这对菲利斯来说是个大日子，但对他来说也是个非常大的日子。他是新娘的雇主。嗯，然后菲利斯有一个谈话头解释她要求迈克尔参加婚礼的原因。她说她要得到一个六周的假期。是的。六周的蜜月。这从来没做过。所以她有她的动机。她确实有。而且她要为此买单。
She will. She will. She really is. She comes for free, guys. Nothing comes for free. Well, then Pam has a talking head where she says Phyllis used the same invitations as her and Roy. There's a big P and a big R. I have a question for you about this.
她会。她会。她真的是。她免费来了，伙计们。没有什么是免费的。嗯，然后帕姆有一个谈话头，她说菲利斯用了和她与罗伊一样的请柬。有一个大P和一个大R。我有一个关于这个的问题要问你。
because you hold it up. Yeah. I took a screen grab. I looked at it. So you remember your saved-the-date that you handed Angela Martin in conflict resolution? Yeah. That was like shades of purple. That was a save-the-date.
因为你把它举起来了。是的。我截了屏。我看了它。所以你记得你在冲突解决中交给安吉拉·马丁的保存日期吗？是的。那是紫色的色调。那是一个保存日期。
That's different from an invitation. But didn't we say that Pam's bridesmaids were going to have like lilac dresses or something at one point? Yeah. Purple was her color. Purple's not here today, guys. There's orange, turquoise. Yeah, you're right. There's a big jump from whatever her save-the-date idea was.
那和请柬不同。但我们不是说帕姆的伴娘在某个时候会有丁香色的裙子吗？是的。紫色是她的颜色。紫色今天不在这里，伙计们。有橙色，绿松石色。是的，你是对的。从她保存日期的想法到她的婚礼将是什么样子，有一个很大的跳跃。
to what her wedding was going to be. Yeah, some changes were made. Mm-hmm. You're right. Yeah. It ends up being more bluey. But then in Pam's wedding to Jim, she goes back to Lilac. I know.
是的，做了一些改变。嗯。你是对的。是的。它最终变得更蓝了。但在帕姆与吉姆的婚礼上，她回到了丁香色。我知道。
I expected to see more purple people. That's all I'm saying. Well, then Stanley, Jim, and Karen arrive. And we find out that they've both purchased toasters. Yes. I called it the dueling toasters. Stanley's really, really annoyed. Carissa, Caitlin.
我期待看到更多紫色的人。我只是这么说。嗯，然后斯坦利、吉姆和凯伦到了。我们发现他们都买了烤面包机。是的。我称之为决斗烤面包机。斯坦利真的，真的很恼火。卡丽莎，凯特琳。
Caitlin, Nicole, Kimberly, and Angela all said, Stanley bought Phyllis a toaster for her wedding present. Do you think it's the same toaster that he bought for Pam and Roy's wedding that he couldn't return and now he's re-gifting it? A hundred percent. Yes. I think that's part of the joke. Yeah. I wouldn't be surprised if it's in the same wrapping. He just put it on a shelf.
凯特琳、妮可、金伯利和安吉拉都说，斯坦利给菲利斯买了一个烤面包机作为结婚礼物。你认为这是他和帕姆与罗伊婚礼买的同一个烤面包机吗，他无法退货，现在他正在重新赠送它？百分之百。是的。我认为那是笑话的一部分。是的。如果它在同一个包装里，我不会感到惊讶。他只是把它放在架子上。
I feel like Karen and Jim checked the registry. They picked the toaster. maybe Stanley checked the registry and he's like, oh, she wants a toaster. I've got a toaster over here. I need to unload. Yeah. So imagine, you know, Jim and Karen's surprise. They're like, well, wait, it said it was still available on the registry.
我觉得凯伦和吉姆查了登记处。他们选了烤面包机。也许斯坦利查了登记处，他说，哦，她想要一个烤面包机。我这里有一个烤面包机。我需要卸货。是的。所以想象一下，你知道，吉姆和凯伦的惊讶。他们就像，好吧，等等，登记处说它仍然可用。
Yeah, what the heck? I think that's why we get the dueling toasters. I love it. Next, Dwight and Angela arrive separately, but they run into each other in the parking lot. He tells her she looks as beautiful as the queen of England. And this is apparently a very high compliment. Angela really loves it. And then she insists that they, you know, they can't walk in the same.
是的，搞什么鬼？我想这就是为什么我们有决斗烤面包机。我喜欢它。接下来，德怀特和安吉拉分别到达，但他们在停车场碰到了对方。他告诉她她看起来像英国女王一样美丽。这显然是一个非常高的赞美。安吉拉真的很喜欢它。然后她坚持认为他们，你知道，他们不能走在一起。
And she's like, don't linger, break left, left. And Jenna, part of that was improvised because I remember that on the day. And Rain and I had a lot of fun being so silly in that parking lot. But I have to talk a minute about my outfit. Oh, well, you're going to make Hunter Sexton and Kennedy McAllister very happy because they want to know all about. it. I remember wardrobe saying that this was vintage, that they, it was like a vintage suit that they found. It was very much like Jacqueline Kennedy, right? Yes. Jacqueline Kennedy for her husband's inauguration, 1961, wore a pillbox hat and wore this cloth sort of wool coat. This was
她说，别逗留，向左走，左边。而且珍娜，那部分是即兴创作的，因为我记得那天。雷恩和我在那个停车场玩得很开心，表现得很傻。但我必须谈谈我的服装。哦，好吧，你会让亨特·塞克斯顿和肯尼迪·麦卡利斯特非常高兴，因为他们想知道关于它的一切。我记得服装组说这是复古的，他们，这就像他们找到的一套复古西装。这非常像杰奎琳·肯尼迪，对吧？是的。杰奎琳·肯尼迪为她丈夫的就职典礼，1961年，戴了一顶药盒帽，穿了这种布料的羊毛大衣。这在当时是
radical at the time. I looked it up because everyone would have been wearing mink, mink coats, mink hats. And there's Jacqueline in like cloth and wool. It's like what? And I, I forever in my brain thought that her pillbox hat and dress were a shade of blue on that day. Are they not? No. No. So this was so cool. I looked up to see who made her hat.
激进的。我查了一下，因为每个人都会穿水貂，水貂大衣，水貂帽子。而杰奎琳穿着布料和羊毛。就像什么？而且我，我永远在我的大脑里认为她的药盒帽和裙子那天是蓝色的色调。它们不是吗？不。不。所以这太酷了。我查了一下是谁做的她的帽子。
It was made by Halston. And when I did, I found out all of this information. Most people think it was blue because at the time, I guess color film struggled to match real hues and photos. But this dress is actually at the John F. Kennedy Presidential Library and Museum. That's where this outfit is stored. And it is, in fact, beige. Bage, not blue. She wore a beige pillbox hat and a beige coat.
它是Halston做的。当我做的时候，我发现了所有这些信息。大多数人认为它是蓝色的，因为当时，我想彩色胶片很难匹配照片中的真实色调。但这件裙子实际上在约翰·F·肯尼迪总统图书馆和博物馆。这就是这套服装存放的地方。而且它实际上是米色的。米色，不是蓝色。她戴了一顶米色的药盒帽和一件米色的大衣。
Whoa. Yes. And if you look up this image, in so many images, it's blue, except if you look at the cover of Life magazine from the inauguration, it is beige. I mean, I'm a little surprised she wore beige to an inauguration. I know. I thought so, too. She did have a mink, what do you call it, that you put your hands in? Stole.
哇。是的。如果你查这张图片，在很多图片中，它是蓝色的，除非你看就职典礼的《生活》杂志封面，它是米色的。我的意思是，我有点惊讶她在就职典礼上穿米色。我知道。我也这么想。她确实有一件水貂，你叫它什么，你把手放进去的？披肩。
A stole? Is that a stole? I don't know. Is it a muff? Is it a muff? A muff? No, muffs are for your ears. It's a handworm.
披肩？那是披肩吗？我不知道。是暖手筒吗？是暖手筒吗？暖手筒？不，暖手筒是给你的耳朵用的。这是一个暖手器。
It was like a mink, brown mink ball and you put your hands in it. I know exactly what you're talking about. And I just, you can tell you and I are on the cutting edge of fashion. A mink ball. She had a mink ball. She had a mink ball. She put her hands in. And the collar of her coat was trimmed in the same color mink as the ball. She put her hands in. But the whole outfit was beige, very bold. And then the thing that Halston, I think, would really want you to know, because he did an interview about it, is that he spent hours shaping that hat so it would have a perfect rounded dome top. And then when she went outside, the wind began to blow. and she had to put her hand on top
它就像一个水貂，棕色的水貂球，你把手放进去。我知道你说的完全是什么。而且我只是，你可以看出你和我处于时尚的前沿。一个水貂球。她有一个水貂球。她把手放进去。她大衣的领子是用和球一样颜色的水貂修剪的。她把手放进去。但整套服装是米色的，非常大胆。然后Halston，我想，真的希望你知道的事情，因为他做了一个关于它的采访，是他花了几个小时塑造那顶帽子，这样它就会有一个完美的圆形圆顶。然后当她走到外面时，风开始吹。她不得不把手放在上面
to hold the hat and it dented it in the middle. Wait. The shape of the hat that I've become like that's burned in my brain was a mistake because she had to flatten it.
来抓住帽子，它在中间凹陷了。等等。我大脑中已经烧录的帽子的形状是一个错误，因为她不得不把它压平。
She had to hold it to her head. She didn't mean to. It was blowing off. So she grabbed it. And that action put a dent in it. And so it was photographed the whole entire day. This was right at the beginning
她不得不把它按在头上。她不是故意的。它被吹走了。所以她抓住了它。那个动作在上面留下了一个凹痕。所以它整天都被拍照。这就在开始的时候
as she walked out. So it was photographed the whole day with this dent in it. And I mean, within, you know, several days, all across America, people were selling this dented hat to match Jackie's pillbox hat. I cannot believe that her pillbox hat was supposed to be rounded. Oh, yeah, it's supposed to be like a little dome.
当她走出来时。所以它整天都被拍到有这个凹痕。我的意思是，在，你知道，几天之内，全美国的人都在卖这种凹陷的帽子来匹配杰基的药盒帽。我不敢相信她的药盒帽应该是圆的。哦，是的，它应该像一个小圆顶。
I have to say, I think God sent that wind that day because a domed hat would have just looked so silly. But a dented hat. I think the dent was the right move. I don't know. All right. Halston, put on your earmuffs. I'm just saying sometimes there are acts of serendipity.
我不得不说，我认为上帝那天送来了那阵风，因为圆顶帽子看起来太傻了。但凹陷的帽子。我认为凹痕是正确的举动。我不知道。好吧。Halston，戴上你的耳罩。我只是说有时会有机缘巧合。
Jenna thinks the dent was ordained. I don't know. Well, after this scene, Angela, we have a Dwight talking head that will become so relevant and important later at the end of the series. He explains that the shrews have a tradition of getting married while standing in their own graves. And we are not going to forget this later when Dwight. finally marries. We'll get there, but people had to help me in that hole.
珍娜认为凹痕是注定的。我不知道。好吧，在这个场景之后，安吉拉，我们有一个德怀特谈话头，这将在系列结束时变得如此相关和重要。他解释说，施鲁特家族有一个传统，就是在站在自己的坟墓里时结婚。我们以后不会忘记这一点，当德怀特最终结婚时。我们会到那里的，但人们必须在那个洞里帮助我。
Well, so everyone's sort of filtering in. They're signing the guest book, yada, yada. In the meantime, Michael is checking in on Phyllis. He comes into the room. He wants to make sure she's all right. Yeah. He's really taken his role seriously as employer of the bride. This scene is absolutely fantastic. It's famous. It's famous. You know, Ken talked a little bit about how much they laughed while they were doing this scene. We had a lot of people write in. Kat, Marilee, Emily, Stephanie, and Dan all wanted to know if any of the Michael and Phyllis dialogue in this dressing room scene was improvised, specifically the word pungent. Well, guys, that was all in the script. They performed this almost exactly as scripted. I think that just tells you how well
好吧，所以每个人都在过滤进来。他们在签到簿上签名，等等。与此同时，迈克尔正在查看菲利斯。他走进房间。他想确保她没事。是的。他真的认真对待他作为新娘雇主的角色。这个场景绝对太棒了。它很有名。它很有名。你知道，肯谈到了一点他们在做这个场景时笑得有多厉害。我们有很多人写信进来。凯特、玛丽莉、艾米丽、斯蒂芬妮和丹都想知道迈克尔和菲利斯在更衣室场景中的任何对话是否是即兴创作的，特别是“刺鼻”这个词。好吧，伙计们，那都在剧本里。他们几乎完全按照剧本表演。我想这只是告诉你这个场景写得有多好
written this scene is, but we had to ask Phyllis what it was like to film this scene. That scene was unbelievable. We had the best time. I don't know how many times we had to stop to start over because there was one word in particular that we just could not get through and that was pungent. Every time Steve said the word pungent, he would break out into this high-pitched cackle, and then I would start laughing. And then all of a sudden we heard the video village and the sound people outside the door because we were in a small dressing room area with just the camera guy and a sound boom.
但我们不得不问菲利斯拍摄这个场景是什么感觉。那个场景令人难以置信。我们玩得很开心。我不知道我们不得不停下来重新开始多少次，因为有一个词特别，我们就是无法通过，那就是“刺鼻”。每次史蒂夫说“刺鼻”这个词，他就会发出这种尖锐的咯咯笑声，然后我就会开始笑。然后突然我们听到视频村和声音人员在门外，因为我们在一个小更衣室区域，只有摄像师和声音吊杆。
I'm not even sure if the boom guy was in there. So we could hear them cackling and laughing on the outside. So we had to stop. They had to move. They had to go down to the bottom of the stairs and set up down there. I couldn't breathe. I was laughing so hard. I couldn't breathe.
我不确定吊杆员是否在里面。所以我们可以听到他们在外面咯咯笑。所以我们不得不停下来。他们不得不移动。他们不得不走到楼梯底部并在那里设置。我无法呼吸。我笑得太厉害了。我无法呼吸。
He was laughing so hard. And we took, I don't know how many times we started over. And it was all because of the word pungent. It's so pungent. It makes me laugh to think of it now. And the only way I found, because I didn't want to keep ruining the scene from laughing, you know, and the only way I got through that scene was to hold my breath. When I wasn't talking, I literally had to suck it up and hold my breath.
他笑得太厉害了。我们拍了，我不知道我们重新开始了多少次。这一切都是因为“刺鼻”这个词。它太刺鼻了。现在想到它让我发笑。我发现的唯一方法，因为我不想因为笑而继续毁掉场景，你知道，我通过那个场景的唯一方法是屏住呼吸。当我没说话时，我真的不得不吸进去并屏住呼吸。
Otherwise, we just couldn't get through it. It was a very fond memory and one of the best that I can have in my entire life. It was a great few moments there. So when you hear the word pungent, know that all hell broke loose every time we said it. Oh, man, I love that so much. I know. I know. This scene made us laugh at the table read and then it made us fall apart when we watched it.
否则，我们就是无法通过。这是一个非常美好的回忆，是我一生中能拥有的最好的回忆之一。那里有几个很棒的时刻。所以当你听到“刺鼻”这个词时，要知道我们每次说它时，地狱都爆发了。哦，天哪，我太喜欢那个了。我知道。我知道。这个场景让我们在剧本朗读时笑了，然后当我们看它时，我们崩溃了。
What really got me was the word pungent, but it was the breath that Steve took before he said it. Yeah. Oh, man. I wish I could have been a fly on the wall. I would have ruined the takes even as a fly. Oh, my gosh. Well, you know, this scene was supposed to go on. Yes.
真正让我受不了的是“刺鼻”这个词，但那是史蒂夫在说它之前吸的那口气。是的。哦，天哪。我希望我能成为墙上的一只苍蝇。即使作为一只苍蝇，我也会毁掉拍摄。哦，天哪。好吧，你知道，这个场景本来应该继续下去的。是的。
Bob Vance is supposed to come to the door. Yes, it's in the deleted scenes on the DVD. Oh, my gosh. Well, I guess they couldn't get through that part either. Bob comes to the door and he's like, you know, Michael's there. And Michael's like, and he's like, oh, what does that smell? And Michael's like, oh, that was Phyllis. She has some nerves, some wedding jitters.
鲍勃·万斯本来应该来到门口。是的，它在DVD的删除场景中。哦，天哪。好吧，我想他们也无法通过那部分。鲍勃来到门口，他说，你知道，迈克尔在那里。迈克尔说，他说，哦，那是什么味道？迈克尔说，哦，那是菲利斯。她有一些紧张，一些婚礼紧张。
And Phyllis is like, it is not me. And Bob was like, I'm going to go. Oh my gosh. I wish that was still in the episode, I have to say. It's really funny. All right. Well, now Michael has a talking head that, you know, believe it or not, he's only ever been to one other wedding. Jenna, this made me sad.
菲利斯说，那不是我。鲍勃说，我要走了。哦，天哪。我希望那仍然在这一集中，我不得不说。它真的很有趣。好吧。好吧，现在迈克尔有一个谈话头，你知道，信不信由你，他只参加过另一场婚礼。珍娜，这让我很难过。
Oh, I can't deal with Michael's childhood. I know. It rips you up. It's too much for me. Well, he's only been to one other wedding, and it was his mom getting married to Jeff. Yeah. And there's a flashback video. It looks like maybe he peed his pants, you know? Oh, yes. Walking down the aisle is the ring bearer. And he runs out and he says, I hate you. And anyway, it's clearly a traumatic experience for him. And Michael is carrying all of that in now to only the second wedding he's ever been to. Yeah. there's there's so much this this scene is really important because it's meant to justify why Michael behaves the way he does all day you know Michael's trying to heal an old wound here yeah he's trying to make up for the one other horrible wedding he's ever been to you know I feel like this is very relatable if you had a horrible experience back in high school but now you've made it big and you're going back to your reuse you union, you're trying to make up for all that lost time. And I think that's a little similar here
哦，我无法处理迈克尔的童年。我知道。它让你心碎。对我来说太多了。好吧，他只参加过另一场婚礼，那是他妈妈嫁给杰夫。是的。有一个闪回视频。看起来他可能尿裤子了，你知道？哦，是的。走过过道是戒指承载者。他跑出去说，我恨你。总之，这对他来说显然是一次创伤性的经历。迈克尔现在带着所有这些进入他参加过的仅有的第二场婚礼。是的，有太多了，这个场景真的很重要，因为它旨在证明为什么迈克尔整天表现得那样，你知道迈克尔在这里试图治愈一个旧伤口。是的，他试图弥补他参加过的唯一另一场可怕的婚礼。你知道，我觉得如果你的高中经历很糟糕，但现在你成功了，你回到你的重聚，你试图弥补所有那些失去的时间，这是非常相关的。我认为这里有点相似
with Michael. I think the other thing going on here, too, is that once again, Michael sees his co-workers as his family. So he really thinks he has a bigger role in this wedding than he does. Yes. So now folks are entering the church, right? They're arriving for the ceremony. And Dwight and Jim have this exchange. Dwight's like, who are all these people? Yeah. He clearly doesn't like crowds. He says, he has this line. He says, we need a new plague. There's too many people. Did you say plague?
和迈克尔。我认为这里发生的另一件事是，迈克尔再次将他的同事视为他的家人。所以他真的认为他在这个婚礼中扮演的角色比他实际扮演的角色更大。是的。所以现在人们正在进入教堂，对吧？他们正在到达仪式。德怀特和吉姆有这种交流。德怀特说，这些人都是谁？是的。他显然不喜欢人群。他说，他有这句台词。他说，我们需要一场新的瘟疫。人太多了。你说瘟疫了吗？
What? Plague. Plague. There's an A. Have you said plague your whole life? Yeah, plague. We need a new plague. Oh, my God.
什么？瘟疫。瘟疫。有一个A。你这辈子都说瘟疫吗？是的，瘟疫。我们需要一场新的瘟疫。哦，天哪。
I'm saying plague. Plague. It's a plague. Plague. I'm saying plague. I cannot believe I'm saying something correctly and you're not. Let's go buy a lottery ticket. Anything can happen.
我说的是瘟疫。瘟疫。这是一场瘟疫。瘟疫。我说的是瘟疫。我不敢相信我说的东西是正确的，而你不是。让我们去买张彩票。什么都可能发生。
All right, he says we need a new plague. Thank you. Well, we had a fan question from Brianna Everett, who wants to know, did Dwight improvise that line about the plague? No, that was scripted. I mean, this episode was really well written. It really was. So I feel like there's a lot of lines that feel like they're improvised, but they were written. That was written.
好吧，他说我们需要一场新的瘟疫。谢谢。好吧，我们有一个来自布里安娜·埃弗雷特的粉丝问题，她想知道，德怀特是即兴创作了关于瘟疫的那句台词吗？不，那是剧本写的。我的意思是，这一集写得真的很好。它确实是。所以我感觉有很多台词感觉像是即兴创作的，但它们是写出来的。那是写出来的。
So now Dwight has this in his head that people are crashing the wedding and he's going to have to go find them. them, Jenna. He's a man on a mission. And everyone else is arriving and they're sort of like mingling and talking. Yes, Kevin introduces himself to Toby's date, who he does not believe Toby met at the gym. He's like, basically implying she's a hired escort. This is classic pervy Kevin. We had some fan questions from Cassidy Hill, Alison Lolis, and Lisa Rice. Is Toby's a hired escort or did Toby really meet this beautiful woman at a gym and why don't we ever see her again? Well, I'll tell you. I don't know why we never see her again. Well, there was a talking head in the script. After she catches the bouquet at the end, Toby says that she's a pediatric nurse.
所以现在德怀特脑子里有这个想法，人们正在闯入婚礼，他将不得不去找到他们。他们，珍娜。他是一个有使命的人。其他人都在到达，他们有点像在社交和交谈。是的，凯文向托比的约会对象介绍自己，他不相信托比是在健身房认识她的。他就像，基本上暗示她是一个雇来的护送。这是经典的色狼凯文。我们有一些来自卡西迪·希尔、艾莉森·洛利斯和丽莎·赖斯的粉丝问题。托比的是雇来的护送吗，还是托比真的在健身房认识了这个美丽的女人，为什么我们再也没见过她？好吧，我会告诉你。我不知道为什么我们再也没见过她。好吧，剧本里有一个谈话头。在她最后接到花束后，托比说她是一名儿科护士。
Yes. But that was cut out of the episode. That is in the DVD box set. There you go. So it was a deleted scene. I believe that she's a pediatric nurse. Yeah. Yeah. Well, also we have a quick moment, a little joke that I really like, which is that Kelly has worn white to the wedding. It looks like a wedding dress with a tiara. I know.
是的。但那被从这一集中剪掉了。那在DVD盒装里。给你。所以那是一个删除的场景。我相信她是一名儿科护士。是的。是的。好吧，我们还有一个简短的时刻，一个我真的很喜欢的笑话，那就是凯利在婚礼上穿了白色。看起来像一件带头饰的婚纱。我知道。
Yeah, tiara. Tierra. I'm going to let that one slide. All right. Well, now it is Michael's moment. He's about to walk Phyllis down the aisle. He's about to start pushing Elbert. Yes, folks.
是的，头饰。头饰。我会让那个滑过去。好吧。好吧，现在是迈克尔的时刻。他正要带菲利斯走过过道。他正要开始推埃尔伯特。是的，伙计们。
Did you hear that? Albert. I got into a big debate with my family. They were positive that he was saying Albert. And I said, no, it's Albert. I know I'm hearing Elbert. It's weird because her father's name is Elbert. And then there's Uncle Al.
你听到了吗？阿尔伯特。我和我的家人进行了一场大辩论。他们肯定他在说阿尔伯特。我说，不，是埃尔伯特。我知道我听到的是埃尔伯特。这很奇怪，因为她父亲的名字是埃尔伯特。然后有阿尔叔叔。
But it's Albert. Albert. Correct. Thank you. Well, as the doors open, we reveal Phyllis in her wedding dress. And Pam turns to camera and says, oh, my God, that's my dress. So she has stolen the invitations, and now her wedding dress. We had a fan question, Angela, from Kaylee Connolly, and I'm going to need your input here.
但它是阿尔伯特。阿尔伯特。正确。谢谢。好吧，当门打开时，我们揭示了菲利斯穿着她的婚纱。帕姆转向镜头说，哦，天哪，那是我的裙子。所以她偷了请柬，现在是她的婚纱。安吉拉，我们有一个来自凯莉·康诺利的粉丝问题，我需要你在这里输入。
Okay. She says, throughout this episode, Pam realizes that Phyllis has stolen all of her wedding details. And then she's wearing the same dress. Well, in the season finale, Angela looks like she's wearing the same dress that Phyllis wore. in her wedding to Dwight. Was this planned? Okay. So I wrote this down too. You guys, when we were watching it, I was watching it with the kids. I said, oh my gosh, that's my dress. And then the kids were like, no, you mean it's Pam's dress? I said, no, it's my dress. And I have all these photos on my phone. I took a ton of photos for the finale, Jenna, of my wardrobe fitting, all of it. It is
好吧。她说，在这一集中，帕姆意识到菲利斯偷了她所有的婚礼细节。然后她穿着同样的裙子。好吧，在季终集中，安吉拉看起来像穿着菲利斯在婚礼上穿的同样的裙子。在与德怀特的婚礼上。这是计划好的吗？好吧。所以我把这个也写下来了。你们，当我们看它时，我和孩子们一起看。我说，哦，天哪，那是我的裙子。然后孩子们就像，不，你是说那是帕姆的裙子？我说，不，那是我的裙子。而且我的手机里有所有这些照片。我为季终集拍了很多照片，珍娜，关于我的服装试穿，所有这些。它是
almost identical. I don't think this was planned, obviously. I don't think Angela Martin would try to emulate Phyllis's dress. I think it was by chance. But you guys, it is so similar. I had a little lace, shawl jacket thing. It didn't come long sleeve. Like Phyllis's goes all the way to her wrists, you know. Mine went sort of just to the elbow area. And then we had a strapless kind of dress. I do not have a broad ribbon band on mine, like her. hers, but it's super similar. I looked it up too. I had pictures side by side on my computer. They are so, it's like the cut of the dress is so similar. Crazy. I know. Okay, so they're walking down the aisle. And as they get about halfway down, Albert is sort of moved to stand up. He's
几乎一模一样。显然，我觉得这不是计划好的。我不认为安吉拉·马丁会试图模仿菲利斯的婚纱。我觉得这纯属巧合。但是伙计们，它真的太像了。我有一件蕾丝披肩外套。它不是长袖的。就像菲利斯的婚纱一直延伸到手腕，你知道的。我的只到手肘附近。然后我们穿的是那种无肩带的裙子。我的裙子上没有像她那样宽的丝带，但它真的超级像。我也查过了。我的电脑上有两张照片并排在一起。它们太像了，裙子的剪裁简直一模一样。太疯狂了。我知道。好吧，他们正走在过道上。当他们走到一半时，阿尔伯特有点想站起来。他是
like, he wants to try, right? It's his daughter's wedding. And Phyllis is so delighted. She just starts to smile and everyone applauds and Michael is like no freaking way. He had one job. He had one job and they just took it away from him. Yes. And he just reverts back to that little boy who didn't get to walk down the aisle with the rings and the dog took his spot. So Michael is just watching Phyllis and her father walk down the aisle to all of this applause. What he does is just sort of awkwardly pushes slash drags the wheelchair
那种，他想尝试一下，对吧？这是他女儿的婚礼。菲利斯非常高兴。她开始微笑，每个人都鼓掌，迈克尔却觉得这简直不可理喻。他本来有一项任务。他只有一项任务，结果却被他们夺走了。是的。他又变回了那个没能和戒指一起走过过道，还被狗抢了位置的小男孩。所以迈克尔只是看着菲利斯和她父亲在掌声中走过过道。他所做的只是尴尬地推着或拖着轮椅
down the aisle behind them so here's my question Jenna because you have the script I sort of figured in the script it would say
在他们身后走过过道，所以这是我的问题，珍娜，因为你有剧本，我原以为剧本里会写
Michael awkwardly walks behind them was that dragging of the wheelchair was that Steve or was that in the script? Oh Angela
迈克尔尴尬地跟在他们身后，那拖着轮椅的动作是史蒂夫即兴发挥的，还是剧本里写的？哦，安吉拉
you are not the only person to wonder so I did look this up because Camille Sarah Dylan Megan and Katie
你不是唯一一个有此疑问的人，所以我查了一下，因为卡米尔、莎拉、迪伦、梅根和凯蒂
all asked the same question Yes, it was scripted. Here's what it says in the script. It says, Michael can't figure out how to undo the lock on the wheelchair, so he drags it down while still doing a traditional wedding walk. Amazing. Yeah. So all of that of him doing the like step together, step together, that was, you know, a script note.
都问了同样的问题。是的，这是剧本写的。剧本里是这样写的：迈克尔不知道怎么解开轮椅的锁，所以他一边拖着轮椅，一边继续走着传统的婚礼步伐。太棒了。是的。所以他那种“迈步、并拢、再迈步”的动作，你知道的，那是剧本里的备注。
Well, we asked Phyllis about this moment, and here's what she had to say. One of the scenes that stood out in my mind was when I was walking down the aisle, and since I've never been married, to me that was a real thrill. And then Michael, Steve, Michael, when he started dragging the wheelchair after my dad had gotten up and was going to walk me down the aisle and Michael was dragging the wheelchair, I could not keep a straight face. And I was so happy that the majority of the time, my back was to that action because it was just hard to keep it in. Just the sound of the wheelchair dragging down the aisle. I remember that. I remember it was very hard to get through. Jenna, I don't know if you remember, but I sat directly behind you.
嗯，我们问过菲利斯关于这一刻的感受，她是这样说的。我脑海中印象最深的一个场景是我走过过道的时候，因为我从未结过婚，对我来说那真的很令人激动。然后迈克尔，史蒂夫，迈克尔，当他在我父亲起身准备陪我走过过道后开始拖着轮椅时，我简直无法保持严肃。我很高兴大部分时间我的背对着那个动作，因为真的很难忍住不笑。光是轮椅拖过过道的声音。我记得那个。我记得当时很难演下去。珍娜，我不知道你还记不记得，但我当时就坐在你正后方。
No. Yes. And we were tickled because between scenes, we could turn around and chat to each other. Well, it's funny because someone pointed out that it seemed like all of the Dunder-Mifflin employees were. on one side except for Pam. Yes. Usually there's a bride's side and a groom's side, but I guess we sat on the groom's side. But I do remember, I have such a memory of how beautiful the back of your hair looked.
不。是的。我们当时觉得很有趣，因为在场景切换间隙，我们可以转过身聊天。嗯，很有趣，因为有人指出，似乎所有的邓德·米夫林员工都坐在同一侧，除了帕姆。是的。通常会有新娘方和新郎方，但我猜我们坐在了新郎那一侧。但我确实记得，我对你当时后脑勺的发型看起来有多美印象深刻。
It looks so beautiful. I watched this episode, and I just thought I looked fantastic. I'm just to say, I was like, oh, my gosh. You did. My hair looks amazing. That dress, that color, that chocolatey color dress. I'd never seen you in that color before. Personally. Why don't I wear that color more is what I thought. I don't know. I feel like that color inspired me because that was the color of the dress I wore to the golden globes. Remember that time when we met Ben Affleck? Yeah. Yes. Yes. I was like if Pam can wear it, I can wear it. Well, I noticed something else about the wedding guests. What? No, Gino and Leo. Bob Vance did not seem to invite any employees. So Phyllis invited.
看起来太美了。我看了这一集，我觉得自己看起来棒极了。我只想说，我当时心想，天哪。你确实很美。我的头发看起来太棒了。那件裙子，那个颜色，那种巧克力色的裙子。我以前从没见过你穿那个颜色。个人而言。我心想，为什么我不穿那个颜色多一点呢？我不知道。我觉得那个颜色启发了我，因为那是我穿去金球奖的裙子的颜色。还记得我们见到本·阿弗莱克的那次吗？是的。是的。我当时想，如果帕姆能穿，我也能穿。嗯，我还注意到了婚礼宾客的其他事情。什么？不，吉诺和利奥。鲍勃·万斯似乎没有邀请任何员工。所以菲利斯邀请了
all of her work friends, but I didn't see a big bunch of Vance refrigeration people. Well, you only know two of them, really. Gino and Leo. Maybe Phyllis was like, those two will do something. They're always up to something. They're on my list. They're on my no list. Yeah.
她所有的工作伙伴，但我没看到一大群万斯制冷公司的人。嗯，你其实只认识他们中的两个。吉诺和利奥。也许菲利斯心想，这两个人会搞出点什么动静。他们总是鬼鬼祟祟的。他们在我的名单上。我的“拒绝名单”上。是的。
Well, I'm sure Bob was like, we're inviting Michael, but I can't bring Gino and Leo. I don't think Bob cared. Well, I don't know if you noticed in the line of groomsmen standing up there. there are a set of twins. Those are meant to be Bob's grown sons. Oh. It's in the script that Bob's twin sons are standing up for him. So he has his best friend and who gives a little bit of a speech later and then his twin sons.
嗯，我敢肯定鲍勃当时想的是，我们邀请了迈克尔，但我不能带吉诺和利奥。我不觉得鲍勃会在意。嗯，我不知道你有没有注意到站在那里的伴郎团。有一对双胞胎。那是鲍勃成年的儿子们。哦。剧本里写着鲍勃的双胞胎儿子在为他担任伴郎。所以他有他的好朋友，后来还发表了一小段演讲，然后是他的双胞胎儿子。
And then I don't know who the other man is meant to be, but no Gino and Leo. So Phyllis is now a stepmom. Yeah. The minister is trying to finish the vows. but Michael jumps the gun and he pronounces Bob and Phyllis man and wife. He had to get something in there. And it's crickets because the vows aren't finished everyone. You know what the best job for Michael would have been is if he could have just been the DJ at the reception.
然后我不知道另一个人是谁，但没有吉诺和利奥。所以菲利斯现在是继母了。是的。牧师正试图完成誓词，但迈克尔抢先一步，宣布鲍勃和菲利斯结为夫妻。他必须得插上一脚。结果全场鸦雀无声，因为誓词还没念完呢，各位。你知道迈克尔最适合的工作是什么吗？如果他能当招待会上的DJ就好了。
Just be the person who announces them in. For the first time, I'd like to introduce to you. Yes, that could have been it. Give him a microphone. It would be like at the Dundies for him all over again. He could be like, and now for the first dance and all of it. that well i don't know i don't know if you should give michael a microphone as we will see soon oh yeah well you you know what angela i always like to give shoutouts to our guest actors the minister was played by
只要做那个宣布他们入场的人。第一次，我想向大家介绍……是的，那本来可以是他做的。给他一个麦克风。对他来说，那就像是又一次“邓迪奖”颁奖典礼。他可以像说，“现在是第一支舞”之类的。嗯，我不知道，我不知道你是否应该给迈克尔一个麦克风，我们很快就会看到。哦，是的，嗯，你知道吗，安吉拉，我总是喜欢向我们的客串演员致敬，牧师是由
rick scary and michael does finally get it right everyone cheers and he's he's a little happy with that moment he's like oh good and he should have just left it alone he had his moment michael but michael can't leave it alone you guys no and it's all going to blow up at the the reception. Roxanne. All right. Well, let's take a break. And when we come back, we'll talk about what happens.
里克·斯卡里扮演的，迈克尔最终确实做对了，每个人都在欢呼，他对那一刻感到有点高兴，他心想，哦，太好了。他本该就此打住的，他已经有了属于他的时刻，迈克尔，但迈克尔就是停不下来，伙计们。不，这一切都要在招待会上爆发了。罗克珊。好吧，让我们休息一下。回来后，我们再谈谈接下来发生了什么。
The conjuring last rites. On September 5th. I come down here with you in your house. Hooray! Hooray! Array! Array! The Conjuring Last Rites.
《招魂：最后仪式》。9月5日。我和你一起在你家里。万岁！万岁！万岁！万岁！《招魂：最后仪式》。
Only on Theater September 5th. I'm Chris Hadfield. I'm an astronaut, an author, a citizen of planet Earth. Join me for a six-part journey into the systems that power the world. Real conversations with real people who are shaping the future of energy. No politics, no empty talk, just solutions-focused conversations on the challenges we must overcome and the possibilities that lie ahead. This is on energy. Listen wherever you get your podcasts.
仅在影院上映，9月5日。我是克里斯·哈德菲尔德。我是一名宇航员、作家，也是地球的一名公民。加入我，开启一段六部分的旅程，探索驱动世界的系统。与那些正在塑造能源未来的真实人物进行真实对话。没有政治，没有空谈，只有专注于解决方案的对话，探讨我们必须克服的挑战和未来的可能性。这就是《关于能源》。在任何你收听播客的地方收听。
Bank more oncores when you switch to a Scotia Bank banking package. Learn more at scotia bank.com slash banking packages. Conditions apply. Scotia Bank. You're richer than you think. All right. So we are back. We're about to go to Phyllis and Bob's reception. And Angela, it is really hitting me that we were on location this entire episode. Jenna, I wrote about it in my journal. I said, we were on location all week and we got to spend a lot of time in our trailers together because we had no, quote, office set to call home. Oscar and I, Oscar and I played music and danced in my trailer. Oh, and John's trailer was Hangout Central. The guys were playing Madden football in there, and we went us gals and hung out in there, too. Rain actually attempted to teach me how to play Madden.
切换到丰业银行银行套餐，享受更多优惠。在 scotiabank.com/bankingpackages 了解更多信息。适用条件。丰业银行。你比你想象的更富有。好了。我们回来了。我们即将前往菲利斯和鲍勃的招待会。安吉拉，我真的意识到这一整集我们都在外景拍摄。珍娜，我在日记里写过这件事。我说，我们整周都在外景拍摄，我们有很多时间在房车里待在一起，因为我们没有所谓的“办公室布景”可以称之为家。奥斯卡和我，奥斯卡和我会在我的房车里放音乐跳舞。哦，约翰的房车是聚会中心。男士们在那里玩《Madden》橄榄球游戏，我们这些女生也去那里待着。雷恩甚至试图教我怎么玩《Madden》。
Oh, I was horrible, and he was so patient. At one point, our second AD was trying to find us all, and when he came to John's trailer, it was John, Rain, Jenna, Rashida, and me. Us gals took turns hosting lunch. Today I hosted and I realized I spent the morning sprucing up my trailer. Isn't that crazy? I cleaned it and then I lit a candle like I was at home having people over for dinner. Of course you did. Oh my gosh. This is so cute. I think the thing that's striking me, Angela, is that it's true how little time we spent in our trailers when we were back on our Dunder Mifflin set because we would just hang out at our desks between scenes. Exactly. That's why I said we didn't have our office desks. So, Yeah. And I know a lot of these scenes, Jenna, if we weren't in them, they really wanted us to go to our trailer because they didn't want, you know, they didn't want to be looking for us all throughout the church. So when we weren't in scenes, they wanted us to go to our little base camp area. And we didn't do as much background work in this episode as you might think. They really crafted these shots. And Ken kind of talked about that. He had a very specific shot list. And he knew exactly what he wanted to see. And when he wanted to see it, So if you weren't a part of that storytelling, you were back in the trailer.
哦，我太笨了，但他非常有耐心。有一次，我们的第二助理导演想找我们所有人，当他来到约翰的房车时，里面有约翰、雷恩、珍娜、拉什达和我。我们这些女生轮流做东吃午餐。今天轮到我做东，我意识到我花了一上午时间打扫我的房车。这不是很疯狂吗？我打扫了它，然后点了一支蜡烛，就像我在家里请人吃晚饭一样。你当然会这么做。天哪。这太可爱了。安吉拉，让我印象深刻的是，当我们在邓德·米夫林片场时，我们在房车里待的时间是多么少，因为我们会在场景间隙待在办公桌旁。没错。这就是为什么我说我们没有办公室桌子。所以，是的。而且我知道很多场景，珍娜，如果我们不在里面，他们真的希望我们去房车，因为他们不想，你知道，他们不想在整个教堂里到处找我们。所以当我们不在场景中时，他们希望我们去我们的小基地区域。而且这一集中我们做的背景工作并没有你想象的那么多。他们真的精心设计了这些镜头。肯也谈到了这一点。他有一份非常具体的镜头清单。他确切地知道他想看什么，以及什么时候想看，所以如果你不参与那个叙事，你就回房车去。
Yeah. Learning how to play mad and football from Rain Wilson. I guess so. Now that you bring it up, I have a vague memory of rain very patiently trying to teach you all the buttons on that controller. I was horrible. Back at the reception. I guess on the way into the reception, they have a traditional receiving line. Everyone walks through.
是的。向雷恩·威尔逊学习如何玩《Madden》橄榄球。我想是这样。既然你提到了，我隐约记得雷恩非常有耐心地试图教你手柄上的所有按钮。我太笨了。回到招待会。我想在进入招待会的路上，他们有一个传统的迎宾队列。每个人都走过去。
You have a nice little moment with Phyllis. Yes, I say that her dress is so well. white. It's almost blinding. I think I know what the implication is there. Yes, but did you notice that I have little lace gloves on? No. Yes, and I had to wear them the whole week and they drove me crazy. Well, you know they would especially drive you crazy today because you cannot wear lace gloves and operate a smartphone. Oh, right. I wouldn't be able to swipe up or do anything. No. That was my first thought. My first thought, you told me that. But then my other thought is, were they itchy? They were a little too long for my fingers so I had this little like floppy bit and then that's what she said I have a deleted
你和菲利斯有一个不错的互动时刻。是的，我说她的裙子太……白了。简直要闪瞎眼了。我想我知道那里的潜台词是什么。是的，但你注意到我戴着蕾丝小手套了吗？没有。是的，我必须整周都戴着它们，它们让我抓狂。嗯，你知道它们今天尤其会让你抓狂，因为你不能戴着蕾丝手套操作智能手机。哦，对了。我无法滑动屏幕或做任何事情。不。那是我的第一个想法。你告诉我的时候我就想到了。但我的另一个想法是，它们扎人吗？它们对我的手指来说有点太长了，所以我有一点松垮的部分，然后那就是她说的话。我有一个被删减的
talking head where I show up to the church and it's one of the craziest shots I meant to bring it up to Ken dang it it's like he put the camera on the ground Jenna and it's shooting up from the asphalt like under my chin it's not super flattering and I'm looking down and a high above my head is the cross and the steeple of the church it's a very dramatic talking head where I basically say, you know, I like traditional weddings, so let's see what this one's going to be like. And as I'm doing it, I have black gloves on and I'm taking them off slowly. And as I do, underneath are my lace gloves. I adore that detail. That is very funny. So people are milling about, people are kind of like, you know, checking out the food. They're
访谈片段，我出现在教堂里，那是最疯狂的镜头之一。我本想向肯提起的，该死。就像他把摄像机放在地上，珍娜，它从沥青路面上向上拍摄，就在我的下巴下面，这不太好看，我向下看，在我头顶上方是十字架和教堂的尖顶。这是一个非常戏剧性的访谈，我基本上说，你知道，我喜欢传统的婚礼，所以让我们看看这场婚礼会是什么样。当我这么做的时候，我戴着黑色手套，我慢慢地把它们摘下来。当我摘下它们时，下面是我戴的蕾丝手套。我喜欢那个细节。那非常有趣。所以人们在四处走动，人们有点像，你知道，在看食物。他们在
walking around. Kelly finds Pam. And she is like, oh, my God, you must be so miserable right now. Yeah. And Pam's like, I don't know. I'm fine. I'm okay. And she's like, well, she would be freaking out and getting drunk and telling someone she's pregnant. Pam's like, Pam's like, it's a lot of good ideas. I feel like Kelly is a friend of me. I feel like she's one of those types of gals. Like, clearly Pam, Pam, is noticing all of this she really doesn't want anyone to then like rub it in her face but she's like oh my god are you so bummed out because they totally took your wedding and roy's here and jims with someone else i would be miserable yes but it's all under the guise of like are you okay yeah she doesn't care if you're okay no no this is a gossip moment yeah well dwight is determined
走来走去。凯利找到了帕姆。她说，哦，天哪，你现在一定很痛苦吧。是的。帕姆说，我不知道。我很好。我没事。她说，嗯，她会抓狂、喝醉，然后告诉别人她怀孕了。帕姆说，帕姆说，那有很多好主意。我觉得凯利是一个“友敌”。我觉得她是那种类型的女生。显然帕姆，帕姆，注意到了这一切，她真的不想让任何人把这件事往她脸上抹，但她却说，哦，天哪，你是不是很沮丧，因为他们完全抢走了你的婚礼，罗伊在这里，吉姆和别人在一起，我会很痛苦。是的，但这都是以“你还好吗”为幌子。是的，她根本不在乎你是否还好。不，不，这是一个八卦时刻。是的，嗯，德怀特决心
to find the wedding crashers dwight finds an elderly guest at the buffet he's like putting a role in his pocket. I respect that move. I have put bread in my purse before. I've done it too. Yeah. Many times. Many times. I've done it with you. I don't like to be without food. I want to have a snack on me at all times. Okay. So Dwight thinks he's a wedding crusher. He starts asking him all these questions and the man is confused. And Dwight's like, that's it and kicks him out. He kicks him out. And that's when Michael checks in with Phyllis, who's like, is everything okay? He mentions he sent back the chicken because it was undercooked. Phyllis is like, it was fish.
找到婚礼的不速之客。德怀特在自助餐区发现了一位老年客人。他正把一个面包卷放进兜里。我尊重这个举动。我以前也把面包放进过钱包里。我也做过。是的。很多次。很多次。我和你一起做过。我不喜欢没有食物。我希望随时随地都有零食。好吧。所以德怀特认为他是一个不速之客。他开始问他所有这些问题，那个人很困惑。德怀特说，就是这样，然后把他赶了出去。他把他赶了出去。就在那时，迈克尔去查看菲利斯的情况，她问，一切都还好吗？他提到他退回了鸡肉，因为它没熟。菲利斯说，那是鱼。
He's like, I'm on it. Well, we had a fan question from Ashley Brooks. She wanted to know, did either of you have a funny story or a wildcard guest like Michael at your weddings? You know, I didn't. But two people did have sex in the bushes at my wedding. I know one of them. It wasn't me. Well, I know both of them because they were guests at my wedding and they didn't come together.
他说，我这就去处理。嗯，我们有一个来自阿什利·布鲁克斯的粉丝提问。她想知道，你们俩在婚礼上有没有像迈克尔那样有趣的故事或不速之客？你知道，我没有。但在我的婚礼上，有两个人确实在灌木丛里发生了性关系。我知道其中一个。那不是我。嗯，我知道他们两个，因为他们是我婚礼上的客人，而且他们不是一起来的。
What? Oh. Oh, that sounded weird. I don't know that much. I don't know that many details about their rendezvous. You see? I was like, dear in headlights. I was like, what?
什么？哦。哦，那听起来很奇怪。我不知道那么多。我不知道他们幽会的太多细节。你看？我当时就像，受惊的鹿。我当时想，什么？
Oh, dear. They didn't arrive to the wedding. Wedding together. They hooked up at your wedding. Yes. Okay. Well, I can tell you at my wedding, we didn't have a random guest, but my husband really, really, really wanted to have a signature drink. He was like so excited about it. I love a signature drink. I know. He did too. I was like, eh. But he likes a Moscow mule. So he wanted to have the Moscow mule. But he wanted to use, is it bourbon? I'm going to get this wrong. It's actually called a Kentucky mule. They make it a little different. But he wanted everyone as their wedding favor to get a copper. Mug. Do you remember this, Jenna? I love my copper mug. Okay. You took yours home. Yeah. I told Josh, I was like, Josh, people are not going to realize they can take them home. They're not. And he's like, yes, they will. We'll say it's the party favor. They get to take a copper mug home. It engraved on it. It was like our wedding date. I was like, babe, this is really nice. People are not going to take them home. And we got into a little fight about it. It was planning the wedding. Guess what? What? We have 55.
哦，天哪。他们不是一起到达婚礼的。他们在你的婚礼上勾搭上了。是的。好吧。嗯，我可以告诉你，在我的婚礼上，我们没有随机的客人，但我丈夫真的、真的、真的想要一种招牌饮料。他对此感到非常兴奋。我喜欢招牌饮料。我知道。他也喜欢。我当时想，呃。但他喜欢莫斯科骡子。所以他想喝莫斯科骡子。但他想用，是波本威士忌吗？我会弄错的。它实际上叫肯塔基骡子。他们做得有点不同。但他想让每个人作为婚礼伴手礼得到一个铜杯。你记得这个吗，珍娜？我喜欢我的铜杯。好吧。你把你的带回家了。是的。我告诉乔什，我说，乔什，人们不会意识到他们可以把它们带回家。他们不会的。他说，是的，他们会。我们会说这是派对伴手礼。他们可以带一个铜杯回家。上面刻着字。就像我们的婚礼日期。我说，宝贝，这真的很好。人们不会把它们带回家的。我们为此吵了一架。那是在筹备婚礼时。猜猜怎么着？什么？我们有55个
copper mugs. Oh, no. Well, Lee and I both took our mugs home. I knew that that was your wedding favor, probably because you told me. And also, we had a sign. It had your table where you went to get seated, tied in a ribbon with your name, and they said this copper mug is yours to take home. Now, to be fair, Angela, if you had been a guest at your own wedding, would you have read the sign and taken home your mug? Jenna, when it comes to getting free things, I read. Okay. That's it. You know what I wouldn't have read? The instructions on where to park. That's correct. I would have circled around until I figured it out. But I would have known to take the copper mug home. Fair enough. All right. Well, now we have some big news. Scrantinicity is going to be
铜杯。哦，不。嗯，我和李都把我们的杯子带回家了。我知道那是你们的婚礼伴手礼，可能是因为你告诉过我。而且，我们有一个标志。它上面有你的桌号，系着丝带，上面写着你的名字，他们说这个铜杯是你的，可以带回家。现在公平地说，安吉拉，如果你是你自己婚礼上的客人，你会读那个标志并把你的杯子带回家吗？珍娜，当涉及到免费的东西时，我会读。好吧。就是这样。你知道我不会读什么吗？关于在哪里停车的说明。那是对的。我会绕圈子直到我弄明白为止。但我会知道把铜杯带回家。有道理。好吧。嗯，现在我们有一个大新闻。Scrantinicity 将在
playing at Phyllis's reception. Yeah. She hired Kevin's band. Scrantonicity. It's their third gig. Their previous two gigs were for members of their own band. But before they begin playing their set, Kevin asked the crowd, has anyone seen Uncle Al? He has dementia and his family is really worried about him. And then he immediately launches into Roxanne. The timing of that is so perfect. Well, Angela, we got a lot of questions about the band. Becky Hadassiz. Marie, Sam and Sarah all wanted to know, was it really Brian Baumgartner singing at the wedding? And was he really playing the drums? Yes and yes. Yes and yes. And he practiced, you guys. He took it really seriously. He worked so hard on that. And I thought he did such a
菲利斯的招待会上演奏。是的。她雇了凯文的乐队。Scrantonicity。这是他们的第三场演出。他们之前的两场演出是为他们乐队自己的成员准备的。但在他们开始演奏之前，凯文问人群，有人看到阿尔叔叔吗？他患有痴呆症，他的家人非常担心他。然后他立即开始演奏《罗克珊》。那个时机太完美了。嗯，安吉拉，我们收到了很多关于乐队的问题。贝基、哈达西、玛丽、萨姆和莎拉都想知道，真的是布莱恩·鲍姆加特纳在婚礼上唱歌吗？他真的在打鼓吗？是的，是的。是的，是的。而且他练习了，伙计们。他非常认真。他为此付出了很多努力。我觉得他做得
great job. Yeah. Well, I have an observation, Jenna. Wasn't this also the band that was going to play at Pam's wedding? Yep. So put it on the list. Put it on the list. And so, Speaking of, Roy is about to find Pam, and he tells her he is so impressed by all the details at this wedding and that Phyllis has such great taste. Well, Jenna, there is a deleted scene. It's fantastic. Phyllis comes up to Pam at the reception and it's like, hey, you might have noticed that Bob and I use the same after-dinner mints like party favor from your wedding that you had planned. I hope that's okay. And you're like, basically Pam's like, just the mints.
太棒了。嗯，我有一个观察，珍娜。这不也是要在帕姆婚礼上演奏的那个乐队吗？是的。所以把它写在名单上。把它写在名单上。所以，说到这个，罗伊正要去找帕姆，他告诉她，他对这场婚礼的所有细节印象深刻，菲利斯有这么好的品味。嗯，珍娜，有一个被删减的场景。太棒了。菲利斯在招待会上走到帕姆面前说，嘿，你可能注意到了，鲍勃和我用了和你婚礼上计划的一样的餐后薄荷糖作为伴手礼。希望没关系。你基本上说，帕姆说，只是薄荷糖吗？
So wait, can you play it, Sam? I recorded it. Are you enjoying yourself? Oh, yeah, I'm having a great time. Good. You know, I don't know if you noticed, but Bob and I borrowed your idea for the after-dinner, and you were going to have at your wedding.
等等，你能播放一下吗，萨姆？我录下来了。你玩得开心吗？哦，是的，我玩得很开心。很好。你知道，我不知道你有没有注意到，但鲍勃和我借用了你关于餐后薄荷糖的想法，你本来打算在你的婚礼上用的。
Oh, yeah. That and also everything. I mean, the dress and the flowers and the fish and the cake. It didn't really sound like you're keeping track. Oh, it just... You know, I could make an announcement if what you want is credit. No, I... Okay.
哦，是的。那个，还有其他所有东西。我是说，裙子、花、鱼和蛋糕。听起来你并没有在记录。哦，只是……你知道，如果你想要功劳，我可以宣布一下。不，我……好吧。
Oh, maybe I should just move your law. Oh, that is amazing. I mean, how passive-aggressive is that? Would you like me to make an announcement so you can get credit? It's so amazing. Well, we asked Phyllis about this particular storyline, and she actually had some thoughts on the matter. So Sam, play the clip. Pam said, you know, that I'd stole her, everything about her wedding that I had stolen it and that I think the writers kind of liked to write Phyllis kind of snarky
哦，也许我应该只是……哦，那太神奇了。我是说，那有多被动攻击？你想让我宣布一下，这样你就能得到功劳吗？那太神奇了。嗯，我们问过菲利斯关于这个特定的故事情节，她实际上对这件事有一些想法。所以萨姆，播放片段。帕姆说，你知道，我偷了她的，关于她婚礼的一切，我偷了它，而且我觉得编剧们有点喜欢把菲利斯写得有点刻薄
sometimes. Well, when I got to thinking about it, I don't think that Phyllis Vance, Phyllis Lappin Vance stole Pam's ideas and colors and flowers and stuff because she was being. vindictive. I think that Phyllis had an admiration for Pam, and I thought, if Pam likes those colors, then those must be pretty special. So that was always kind of a back story in my mind that I wasn't being nasty, that I was being, you know, kind of honoring Pam's Pam's wishes for her ill-fated wedding, but she ended up having a great wedding, didn't she? Aw, that is just Phyllis being Phyllis. Yeah.
有时。嗯，当我想到它时，我不认为菲利斯·万斯、菲利斯·拉平·万斯偷了帕姆的想法、颜色和花之类的东西，因为她是怀恨在心。我认为菲利斯对帕姆有一种钦佩，我想，如果帕姆喜欢那些颜色，那么它们一定很特别。所以在我脑海中一直有一个背景故事，我不是在使坏，我是在，你知道，有点尊重帕姆对她那场不幸的婚礼的愿望，但她最终还是举办了一场很棒的婚礼，不是吗？啊，那只是菲利斯做回了菲利斯。是的。
Phyllis Smith is so sweet. I do think Phyllis Lappin was a little shady. Yes, I think so too. But it also kind of explains that snarky comment. You know, if that was where she was coming from of like, well, I was just, I admired your choices. but I guess if you need a bunch of credit, you know. Yeah. Well, I think it's sweet because it really speaks to how much Pam shared with Phyllis about her wedding planning.
菲利斯·史密斯太可爱了。我确实认为菲利斯·拉平有点阴险。是的，我也这么认为。但这也有点解释了那个刻薄的评论。你知道，如果那是她的出发点，比如，嗯，我只是，我很钦佩你的选择。但我想如果你需要很多功劳，你知道。嗯，我觉得这很甜，因为它真的说明了帕姆和菲利斯分享了多少关于她婚礼筹备的事情。
And you see little snippets of that where Phyllis is showing an interest like they're in the kitchen and then Jim walks in. But this is the person that Pam could share with at work and was probably the only person who took an interest in her wedding. So I think that's why it was especially surprising to Pam where she was like, oh. Yeah. Oh, yeah. Angela Martin didn't need to hear about your wedding. She probably judged you for doing work on it at work. She did. I think you have a whole thing where you come down on me about it. I know. All right. So now it's time for the speeches, everyone. Bob's best man, Randy, finishes up his speech. And Michael jumps up. He has an amazing line. He's got a 40-minute speech plan. Yeah. It's going to be your host for the next 40 minutes. And it's all like on napkins. Well, a lot of people wanted to know how much of Michael's toast was improvised. Crystal, Sammy, Sarah, Aubrey, and Regan all asked.
你可以看到其中的小片段，菲利斯表现出兴趣，就像他们在厨房里，然后吉姆走进来。但这是帕姆在工作中可以分享的人，可能也是唯一一个对她的婚礼感兴趣的人。所以我认为这就是为什么帕姆特别惊讶的原因，她当时想，哦。是的。哦，是的。安吉拉·马丁不需要听你的婚礼。她可能因为你在工作中做这些事而评判你。她确实评判了。我想你有一整段戏是在工作中因为这件事而责备我。我知道。好吧。所以现在是演讲时间了，各位。鲍勃的伴郎兰迪结束了他的演讲。迈克尔跳了起来。他有一句很棒的台词。他计划了一个40分钟的演讲。是的。他将成为接下来40分钟的主持人。而且全写在餐巾纸上。嗯，很多人想知道迈克尔的祝酒词有多少是即兴的。克里斯托、萨米、莎拉、奥布里和里根都问了。
Also, was it hard to keep a straight face? Well, almost all of that speech was scripted. And yes, it's always hard to keep a straight face. But Phyllis had a different take on this. Here's what she had to say. Anytime Michael opened his mouth, it was hard to keep a straight face. And at that point in the script, he was kind of hurtful, but he didn't even know it. So I didn't really have to strain to keep a straight face on that particular scene because I was so hurt that he was saying all those crummy things about me.
还有，保持严肃很难吗？嗯，那个演讲几乎全是剧本写的。是的，保持严肃总是很难。但菲利斯对此有不同的看法。她是这样说的。迈克尔每次开口，保持严肃都很难。在剧本的那一点上，他有点伤人，但他自己甚至都不知道。所以我不需要费力去保持严肃，因为我真的很受伤，他说了那么多关于我的糟糕的话。
Some true, but some not. No. No. Yeah, I love that Phyllis is like, no, I was so in the moment playing, being. hurt. And this reminds me of her scene in the first Christmas episode when Michael was so rude to her about her homemade oven mitt. And all the rest of us were just cracking up and Phyllis stayed in character. She was hurt. And she didn't break. No, she's a total pro. I mean, she really took all of her, all of the different moments of the script that she was in. She really, really played it
有些是真的，有些不是。不。不。是的，我喜欢菲利斯说，不，我当时完全沉浸在扮演受伤的角色中。这让我想起了她在第一集圣诞特辑中的场景，当时迈克尔对她的自制烤箱手套非常粗鲁。我们其他人都在大笑，而菲利斯保持着角色。她很受伤。她没有笑场。不，她是个十足的专业人士。我是说，她真的把剧本中她参与的所有不同时刻都演得
honest. Well, I want to give a shout out here to Bob's best man. He was played by Brian Douglas Hatton, and he's been in a bunch of stuff, including a recurring role as a detective on monk. Oh, it's another monk person. Another office monk crossover. There you go. Well, I have to point out something that's so ridiculous, but, you know, it is my way. Michael continues his speech and says that their couple's celebrity name would be flob? Yeah. I looked it up. I was like, when did people start doing this?
很真实。嗯，我想在这里向鲍勃的伴郎致敬。他由布莱恩·道格拉斯·哈顿扮演，他演过很多东西，包括在《神探阿蒙》中饰演一名侦探。哦，又是《神探阿蒙》的人。另一个《办公室》和《神探阿蒙》的交叉。就是这样。嗯，我必须指出一些非常荒谬的事情，但是，你知道，这是我的风格。迈克尔继续他的演讲，说他们的名人情侣名字会是“Flob”？是的。我查过了。我当时想，人们是从什么时候开始这么做的？
Like combining the names? And this is what the Internet said, guys. The first time a celebrity couples named was combined was Benifer. I was going to say Benefer. Yes. Ben Affleck and Jennifer Lopez. How does everyone know this? This is like a unanimous thought online that Benefer started at all.
就像组合名字？这就是互联网上说的，伙计们。名人情侣名字组合的第一次是“Bennifer”。我正要说“Bennifer”。是的。本·阿弗莱克和詹妮弗·洛佩兹。每个人怎么都知道这个？这在网上是一个一致的观点，即“Bennifer”开启了一切。
I knew it. There you go. The next one after Benefer was Brangelina. Yes, Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie. And then I guess there's one for Kanye West and Kim Kardashian and it's Kim Ye. Oh, yeah, Kim Ye. I've heard that. I haven't heard that.
我就知道。就是这样。继“Bennifer”之后的下一个是“Brangelina”。是的，布拉德·皮特和安吉丽娜·朱莉。然后我想还有坎耶·韦斯特和金·卡戴珊的，是“Kimye”。哦，是的，“Kimye”。我听说过。我没听说过。
That one is not quite in my vernacular as much as Benifer and Brangelina. But some people pointed out that, you know, Brad Pitt and Jennifer Aniston would have also been a Benifer. No, they would have been a Brenifer. Well, after he does their name mashup, he goes on to do what I think he thinks is like a fun, playful, kind of roast of Phyllis where he tells everyone that her nickname in high school was Easy Rider. Well, that's it for Bob. Bob's like, you're out of here, buddy. And he takes the microphone and he throws Michael out of the wedding. As Michael screams, I hate you.
那个在我的词汇里不像“Bennifer”和“Brangelina”那样常用。但有些人指出，你知道，布拉德·皮特和詹妮弗·安妮斯顿也会是“Bennifer”。不，他们会是“Brenifer”。嗯，在他做完他们的名字组合后，他继续做他认为是有趣、俏皮、某种对菲利斯的调侃，他告诉大家她在高中的绰号是“逍遥骑士”。嗯，鲍勃受够了。鲍勃说，你被解雇了，伙计。他拿过麦克风，把迈克尔赶出了婚礼。迈克尔尖叫着，我恨你。
This is the second time he screamed, I hate you. he screamed, I hate you, at a wedding. This is full circle for him now. He's the little boy all over again, not getting to be part of the wedding. Groom's been out there. If Jenna and I can impart anything on you, don't roast the bride. Yeah. Good one.
这是他第二次尖叫“我恨你”。他在婚礼上尖叫“我恨你”。这对他来说现在是一个完整的循环。他又变回了那个小男孩，没能成为婚礼的一部分。伴郎在那儿。如果珍娜和我能传授给你什么，那就是不要调侃新娘。是的。好建议。
It never goes well. No, it's her day. Yeah. Let her have her day. Yeah. You can roast the groom. Don't roast the bride. All right, we've got a bunch of little moments.
这从来都不会有好结果。不，那是她的日子。是的。让她过好她的日子。是的。你可以调侃新郎。不要调侃新娘。好吧，我们还有一堆小片段。
And we talked with Ken about this. We kind of move into like the rest of the storytelling here in this episode is done in these like little vignettes. We have Jim kind of comes up to Pam and is like, why aren't you going to dance? And it's a little bit of a flirty moment. A little bit. He says you look cute. It's a total flirt moment. Yeah.
我们和肯谈过这个。我们进入了这一集中剩下的叙事，都是通过这些小片段完成的。吉姆走到帕姆面前说，你为什么不去跳舞？这是一个有点调情的时刻。有点。他说你看起来很可爱。这完全是一个调情时刻。是的。
And Pam knows it's a flirt moment. So now she's like, oh. But then, you know, he's off dancing with Karen. This is a series of moments where Jim and Pam both kind of get their hopes up and then gets their get their hopes dash. Michael tries to sneak back in the wedding, but Dwight won't let him in. Dwight's so pleased. He's so pleased to be kicking him out. And then Pam is sort of sulking in a corner, and you hear, you were meant for me by Jewel.
帕姆知道这是一个调情时刻。所以现在她想，哦。但随后，你知道，他去和凯伦跳舞了。这是一系列吉姆和帕姆都燃起希望然后又破灭的时刻。迈克尔试图溜回婚礼，但德怀特不让他进去。德怀特很高兴。他很高兴能把他赶出去。然后帕姆在角落里闷闷不乐，你听到了朱厄尔的《You Were Meant for Me》。
And Roy comes up to Pam and is like, oh, my gosh, they're playing our song. And she's like, yeah, it's so weird. I thought they only played the police. And he's like, well, I gave him 20 bucks. Do you want to dance? Pam is very moved by this. It's thoughtful. It is thoughtful.
罗伊走到帕姆面前说，哦，天哪，他们在放我们的歌。她说，是的，太奇怪了。我以为他们只放警察乐队的歌。他说，嗯，我给了他20块钱。你想跳舞吗？帕姆被此举深深打动了。这很贴心。确实很贴心。
And Roy is really making an effort. And they go and they dance together. And then the camera pans and we see Angela and Dwight have sneaked off and they are dancing together. Yes. So you guys, this shot was really fun to do. We had to do it at night. So we did it one evening. It was outside.
罗伊真的在努力。他们去跳舞了。然后镜头平移，我们看到安吉拉和德怀特溜走了，他们正在一起跳舞。是的。所以伙计们，这个镜头拍起来真的很有趣。我们必须在晚上拍。所以我们在一个晚上拍了它。是在外面。
And Ken, when he had scouted the whole church, found. this back door that then had steps that led down, right? And so we decided to film it there. Those steps actually faced the street, which was a busy street, and we didn't have it blocked off. No one was crossing the street. So it was just people going about their evening. And as we slowed danced in one take, a car drove by with the windows down.
肯在勘察整个教堂时，发现了这扇后门，然后有通往下面的台阶，对吧？所以我们决定在那里拍摄。那些台阶实际上对着街道，那是一条繁忙的街道，我们没有封路。没有人过马路。所以只是人们在过他们的夜晚。当我们一镜到底跳慢舞时，一辆车开过，窗户开着。
And they went, oh, my God, Dwight, Dwight, Angela. And we had to do the takeover again. That's amazing. Oh my gosh, I love that. After this dance, Roy is like, hey, do you want to get out of here? And Pam says yes. And they walk off and they're holding hands and Jim sees it and it just hits you like a ton of bricks. When he watches her leave with him and then he has a talking head where he's like, you know what?
他们喊道，哦，天哪，德怀特，德怀特，安吉拉。我们不得不重拍。太神奇了。哦，天哪，我喜欢那个。跳完舞后，罗伊说，嘿，你想离开这里吗？帕姆说好。他们走开了，手牵着手，吉姆看到了，这就像重锤一样击中了他。当他看着她和他一起离开时，他有一个访谈片段，他说，你知道吗？
I'm glad I'm here with Karen. Yeah. Yeah. And then we have a few moments. Karen's singing with the band. Rashida mentioned this when she came on the podcast that she was so nervous to have to sing. She could not have been more adorable in this moment. When he says, I'm glad I'm with Karen, and then it cuts to her singing and dancing,
我很高兴我和凯伦在一起。是的。是的。然后我们有几个片段。凯伦和乐队一起唱歌。拉什达在播客上提到她不得不唱歌时非常紧张。她在这一刻可爱极了。当他说，我很高兴我和凯伦在一起，然后镜头切到她唱歌跳舞，
she's the cutest person on the planet. She was so stinking cute. Yes. And I think Rashida would be happy to know that Ariana November wrote in to say, is Rashida Jones a trained singer because she is really good. And I thought she had a great voice, too. I did too. I did too.
她是地球上最可爱的人。她太可爱了。是的。我想拉什达会很高兴知道阿丽亚娜·诺文伯写信来说，拉什达·琼斯是受过训练的歌手吗，因为她真的很好。我也觉得她的声音很好。我也这么认为。
And then I even thought, you know, Jim's reaction, like waving his phone in the air. It was cute. Yeah. So then Phyllis tosses her bouquet and Ryan swats it away from Kelly. Kelly was clearly going to catch that bouquet and Ryan swats it away. A lot of people wanted to know if that was a scripted moment. Yes. Yes, it was.
然后我甚至想，你知道，吉姆的反应，像在空中挥舞手机。那很可爱。是的。所以然后菲利斯扔了她的捧花，瑞安把它从凯利那里拍开了。凯利显然要接住那个捧花，瑞安把它拍开了。很多人想知道那是不是剧本里的时刻。是的。是的，它是。
Yeah. Ryan can't let Kelly catch that. that. Do you know what that would do for their relationship? No, no, no. But who does catch it? Toby's date. And I loved so much, Jenna, that one-on-one of Toby to camera where he's like, Toby, yeah. Yeah. Well, now we move outside and Michael is sitting on a bench with Uncle Al. Yeah. And they're having this big heart to heart. How perfect is that? It was such a great scene. We had some people write in, Christy Carol, Conner, Yakes and Ashley Howell all asked, can you talk about the actors that played Uncle Al and Phyllis's
是的。瑞安不能让凯利接住那个。你知道那会对他们的关系产生什么影响吗？不，不，不。但谁接住了它？托比的约会对象。我非常喜欢，珍娜，托比对着镜头的那个特写，他说，托比，是的。是的。嗯，现在我们走到外面，迈克尔正和阿尔叔叔坐在长椅上。是的。他们正在进行一次深入的交谈。那有多完美？那是一个很棒的场景。我们有一些人写信来，克里斯蒂·卡罗尔、康纳·耶克斯和阿什利·豪威尔都问，你们能谈谈扮演阿尔叔叔和菲利斯父亲
dad, Albert, because they were both fabulous. Well, guys, George Ives played Uncle Al, and he was a longtime television actor. He appeared in Mr. Ed, the Andy Griffith Show, My Three Sons, Bewitched, and a bunch of movies. He passed away in 2013, and The Office was his last television show. that he appeared in, according to IMDB. Yeah, and he was just absolutely fabulous. And then Hansford Rowe played Phyllis' father. He passed away in 2017. He was a very accomplished actor.
阿尔伯特的演员吗？因为他们都很棒。嗯，伙计们，乔治·艾夫斯扮演阿尔叔叔，他是一位资深的电视演员。他出现在《艾德先生》、《安迪·格里菲斯秀》、《我的三个儿子》、《神仙家庭》和一堆电影中。他于2013年去世，《办公室》是他出演的最后一部电视剧，根据IMDB显示。是的，他绝对太棒了。然后汉斯福德·罗扮演菲利斯的父亲。他于2017年去世。他是一位非常有成就的演员。
Listen to the movies he's been in. He was in Dante's Peak, Baby Boom, Three Days of the Condor. He's been in a ton of television shows. modern family will and grace curb your enthusiasm six feet under but here's the one that got me he was in this mini series called v do you remember v was it about aliens taking over yes and then you it was from the 80s yeah people would do the sign the v the little sign with their fingers yeah and the way you found out they were aliens is they would peel off their skin and they were like lizard people underneath. Yeah. Oh my God. I forgot about that show. Remember how shocking it was when you
听听他演过的电影。他演过《但丁峰》、《婴儿潮》、《秃鹰三天》。他演过很多电视剧。《摩登家庭》、《威尔和格蕾丝》、《抑制热情》、《六尺之下》，但这是让我震惊的一个，他出演过一部叫《V》的迷你剧。你记得《V》吗？是关于外星人接管地球的吗？是的，然后你，那是80年代的。是的，人们会做那个V的手势，用手指做那个小手势。是的，你发现他们是外星人的方式是他们会剥掉皮肤，下面是蜥蜴人。是的。哦，天哪。我忘了那个节目了。记得当你
saw their lizards? Yeah. Well, listen, we had a fan question from Sierra, Katie Regan, Katie Slump, Allison and Lexi. They all noticed that at 19 minutes, 30 seconds, as Phyllis is leaving the church, she seems to have a black brace on her right knee. Well, guys, I asked Phyllis about this, And she does not remember. She was definitely not injured during the making of this episode. But, you know, she said she went through a few injuries during her time on the show. And I guess this must have been when she was favoring that knee a little bit. But I stopped it.
看到他们的蜥蜴样子时有多震惊吗？是的。嗯，听着，我们有一个来自塞拉、凯蒂·里根、凯蒂·斯兰普、艾莉森和莱克西的粉丝提问。他们都注意到在19分30秒，当菲利斯离开教堂时，她的右膝盖上似乎有一个黑色护具。嗯，伙计们，我问过菲利斯这件事，她不记得了。她在拍摄这一集时绝对没有受伤。但是，你知道，她说她在节目期间经历过几次受伤。我想这一定是她当时有点偏袒那个膝盖的时候。但我暂停了。
And sure enough, there is a little bit of a bandage there. I did not catch that. Yeah. Oh, man. We have really good background catchers that watch the show. We do. Well, now we have this tag, this little scene at the end. And it's Bob and Phyllis.
果然，那里有一点绷带。我没注意到。是的。哦，伙计。我们有非常好的背景捕捉者在看节目。我们确实有。嗯，现在我们有这个尾声，最后的小场景。那是鲍勃和菲利斯。
They're doing that thing where you shove the wedding cake in the face kind of thing. And of course, Michael wants to get in on it. It's really awkward. I don't know if you noticed on this cake. It was so amazing. It was so well done. There was a full silver refrigerator made of fondant that sat on top of the cake as like the to the topper next to the little bride and groomed figurine.
他们正在做那种把婚礼蛋糕塞进对方脸上的事情。当然，迈克尔想参与其中。这真的很尴尬。我不知道你有没有注意到这个蛋糕。它太神奇了。做得太好了。蛋糕顶上有一个完整的翻糖做的银色冰箱，作为装饰，放在新娘和新郎小雕像旁边。
I did not notice that. Yes. That is brilliant. Of course. Of course there was a Vance refrigeration. on the top of the cake with them. That was also cake. So you know how you take the top part of the cake and you save it and you have it on your
我没注意到那个。是的。那太天才了。当然。当然，蛋糕顶上有万斯制冷公司。那也是蛋糕。所以你知道你是怎么把蛋糕顶端拿下来，保存起来，然后在你的
one-year anniversary? Yeah. They're going to eat that refrigerator. They're one-year anniversary. Did you do that? Did you save the top of your cake and eat it a year later? No. Did you?
一周年纪念日吃掉它的吗？是的。他们要吃掉那个冰箱。他们的一周年纪念日。你做了吗？你保存了蛋糕顶端并在一年后吃掉它了吗？没有。你呢？
Oh, no. You know what? It's weird. I can't remember. But this past year, we just celebrated our 10th wedding anniversary. Lee and I, 10 years this year. That's amazing, lady. Well, and it happened during a pandemic.
哦，不。你知道吗？这很奇怪。我不记得了。但过去这一年，我们刚刚庆祝了我们的10周年结婚纪念日。李和我，今年10年了。那太棒了，女士。嗯，而且它发生在疫情期间。
And we had these plans that for our 10th wedding anniversary, we wanted to take a big trip and take the kids to the spot where Lee proposed to me. And I wanted to have a family portrait taken in this spot. And that was, I mean, I've been had this in my head for like years since our seventh wedding anniversary. Yes, that this would be such a fun way to mark our 10th wedding. wedding anniversary. Well, you know, then we couldn't really go anywhere because our anniversary is in July. So we ended up having dinner outside underneath our fruit trees and our original wedding planner, Beth Helmstetter, you know her. She set it all up for us. She came over. She wore a
我们曾计划在结婚十周年纪念日时进行一次盛大的旅行，带孩子们去李向我求婚的地方。我想在那里拍一张全家福。从我们结婚七周年纪念日开始，我就一直有这个念头，觉得这将是纪念我们结婚十周年的绝佳方式。然而，由于我们的纪念日是在七月，当时我们哪儿也去不了。所以我们最终在果树下的户外吃了晚餐，我们的婚礼策划师贝丝·赫尔姆斯泰特（Beth Helmstetter）——你认识她——为我们安排了一切。她过来了，戴着一个
mask. She set this little table out under our trees. And do you know what she did for us? What? She had the records from our wedding. And she had a tiny replica of our wedding cake made for us for four people so that our kids could eat our wedding cake on our 10th wedding anniversary. That is so special. That is so sweet. I wanted to tell you though, we didn't eat the top of our cake. That wasn't the type of cake we had at our wedding, but I have to tell you our topper story, which is, you know, we're a blended family. We were two whole families coming together. So our children were a really big part of our wedding. They all wanted to speak at the ceremony. And then when it came time for the cake, instead of getting a traditional
口罩。她在树下摆了一张小桌子。你知道她为我们做了什么吗？什么？她准备了我们婚礼上的唱片。她还为我们定制了一个四人份的婚礼蛋糕微缩模型，这样我们的孩子们就能在我们的结婚十周年纪念日上吃到我们的婚礼蛋糕了。那真是太特别了。太贴心了。不过我想告诉你，我们并没有吃蛋糕顶部的装饰。那不是我们婚礼上用的那种蛋糕，但我必须讲讲我们的蛋糕顶饰的故事。你知道，我们是一个重组家庭，是两个完整的家庭走到了一起。所以我们的孩子们在婚礼中扮演了非常重要的角色。他们都想在仪式上发言。当切蛋糕的时候，我们没有用传统的
bride and groom figurine, we let the kids design this out of Legos. Oh, that's right. And so we had a little Lego, sort of like they made like a little archway out of Legos, and then they put little Lego flowers on the white archway. And then they made Legos of me and Josh and then of each of them. So all three kids. So we had five little Legos under a Lego Archway on top of our wedding cake. So sweet. So cute, right? And we saved it. It's on our mantle. Well, Lady, I just love all that. So we did get some questions about this cake scene. And guys, I want to let you know. So this was originally shot to be earlier in the episode. And then they just liked it. So they used it as the tag. But it was meant to go right before Dwight confronts Uncle Al for stealing the bread at the buffet and throws them out.
新郎新娘人偶，而是让孩子们用乐高积木设计了一个。哦，没错。他们用乐高搭了一个小拱门，还在白色的拱门上放了乐高小花。然后他们用乐高拼出了我和乔什，还有他们每个人。所以三个孩子都在。我们在婚礼蛋糕顶上放了五个乐高小人，站在乐高拱门下。太甜了。太可爱了，对吧？我们把它保存了下来，现在放在我们的壁炉架上。天哪，我太喜欢这些了。关于这个蛋糕场景，我们确实收到了一些问题。伙计们，我想告诉你们，这段戏原本是安排在剧集前段拍摄的。后来他们很喜欢，就把它用作了片尾彩蛋。但它原本是打算放在德怀特因为阿尔叔叔在自助餐偷面包而与他对峙并把他赶出去之前的。
There were some questions about why this was at the end of the episode. It was just sometimes we do that. Sometimes, you know, we cut back to a moment that might have happened earlier as our tag. Well, that's the fun thing about a cold open and a tag. Sometimes they don't have to be in sort of a time ordered manner. Yes. Yes. Well, the original tag of this episode was supposed to be a series of,
有人问为什么这段戏放在了剧集结尾。有时候我们就是会这样做。有时候，你知道，我们会把可能发生在早些时候的片段剪辑回来作为片尾彩蛋。嗯，这就是冷开场和片尾彩蛋的有趣之处。有时候它们不一定非要按时间顺序排列。是的。是的。嗯，这一集的原始片尾彩蛋原本是一系列
of photos where Michael is photo bombing every single picture. I remember taking these pictures and you can find some of them. You can. Where are they? Office Talley, maybe? Yeah. So for a while, NBC had these photos up on their website and I don't think they're there anymore, but I'm going to do a little digging and if we can find them, we'll put them up on the pod.
迈克尔在每张照片里乱入的照片。我记得拍这些照片的情景，你们可以找到其中的一些。真的吗？它们在哪儿？《办公室》的塔利（Talley）网站吗？也许吧。有一段时间，NBC把这些照片放在了他们的网站上，我想现在应该不在了，但我会去挖掘一下，如果我们能找到，我们会把它们放到播客里。
But I remember shooting them. It was very, very funny. Yeah, I remember those too. Well, you know, Jenna, we asked Phyllis about the cake and just about this episode. So things she remembered and things that stood out to her, and here's what she had to say. Yes, it was very good cake. And we didn't really do that many takes of it. It was the end of the night.
但我记得拍摄它们的时候，非常非常有趣。是的，我也记得。嗯，你知道，珍娜，我们问了菲利斯关于蛋糕和这一集的事情。关于她记得的事情和让她印象深刻的事情，以下是她所说的。是的，蛋糕非常好吃。我们并没有拍太多次。那是那天晚上的最后一场戏。
They didn't want to mess my face and hair up every time. So I think we just practiced it without messing it all over our faces. And then we did it just the one time. So, no, we didn't do that multiple times where it had to be cleaned up and this and that. And then Michael went crazy. of course, smearing it all over his face. And, you know, one of the funniest scenes that I think that tore me up when I saw it for the first time
他们不想每次都弄乱我的脸和头发。所以我想我们只是练习了一下，没有把蛋糕弄得满脸都是。然后我们只拍了一次。所以，不，我们没有拍很多次，不需要清理什么的。然后迈克尔就疯了，当然，把蛋糕抹得满脸都是。而且，你知道，我认为最有趣的场景之一，当我第一次看到它时让我笑得不行
was when Michael was outside jumping at the window trying to look in after he had been escorted out by Dwight. I don't know, for some reason, that just really tore me up. I thought that whole wedding was, of course I would, was a remarkable episode. Everybody had their shining moments in it. Kelly dressed in white and the whole Pam and Jim, Karen, Roy Triangle, that was all great. It was just pretty special. And Ken, I think Ken directed that. He was fantastic. I always enjoyed working with him. and we were so blessed on that show.
是迈克尔被德怀特赶出去后，在窗外跳着试图往里看的时候。我不知道，出于某种原因，那真的让我笑得不行。我觉得整场婚礼，当然我会这么觉得，是一集非常出色的剧集。每个人在其中都有闪光的时刻。凯莉穿着白色的衣服，还有帕姆、吉姆、凯伦和罗伊的三角关系，这一切都很棒。这真的很特别。而且肯，我想是肯执导的。他太棒了。我一直很喜欢和他合作。我们在那部剧里真是太幸运了。
We had so many great writers, directors, and the fact that we all got to grow up together on the show, basically, not just this episode, the whole nine seasons. And it was really a blessing then and continues to be to this day. I'm glad you enjoyed the episode. I'm assuming you did. And I'll talk to you later. Well, now we're wrapping up the episode.
我们有那么多优秀的编剧、导演，而且我们所有人都在这部剧里一起成长，基本上不仅是这一集，而是整整九季。那在当时是一种福气，直到今天依然如此。很高兴你喜欢这一集。我假设你喜欢。回头再聊。好了，现在我们要结束这一集了。
But Jenna, before we say goodbye, I have to talk about a few deleted scenes. One, I talked about with Ken Whittingham, about Angela's Whole Runner with Dennis. Dennis, the veterinarian. Yes. She says, I'm sorry, but I'm with someone. She does end up turning Dennis down. But here are the two other deleted scenes that were so funny to me. Number one, Kevin has a talking head.
但是珍娜，在我们说再见之前，我必须谈谈几个删减片段。其中一个我曾和肯·惠廷汉姆（Ken Whittingham）聊过，关于安吉拉和丹尼斯的那条故事线。丹尼斯，那个兽医。是的。她说，对不起，但我已经有对象了。她最终确实拒绝了丹尼斯。但这里有两个我觉得非常有趣的删减片段。第一，凯文有一个采访镜头。
He says that he has proposed. to four different girls. Oh, my gosh. Four. But Stacey was the first one to say yes. And, you know, if it couldn't be Melissa Riley, then he's glad it was Stacey. Wow. Who the heck is Melissa Riley?
他说他已经向四个不同的女孩求婚了。天哪。四个。但史黛西是第一个答应的。而且，你知道，如果不是梅丽莎·莱利（Melissa Riley），那他很高兴是史黛西。哇。梅丽莎·莱利到底是谁？
I don't know. Okay, I thought that was delicious. And this is the other one. I loved. Wedding Planners, Listen Up. There is a deleted scene where Meredith holds up a party favor. and it's a little tiny refrigerator magnet. And when you open the door to the refrigerator,
我不知道。好吧，我觉得那太有意思了。这是另一个我喜欢的。婚礼策划师们，听好了。有一个删减片段是梅雷迪思举起一个派对伴手礼，那是一个小小的冰箱贴。当你打开冰箱门的时候，
there's a picture of Phyllis and Bob. Wow. Yeah. Well, she didn't steal that from Pam's wedding. She didn't steal that one. But don't you wish you had that magnet, that little refrigerator magnet? So in the deleted scene, we see this item?
里面有一张菲利斯和鲍勃的照片。哇。是的。好吧，她没有从帕姆的婚礼上偷那个。她没偷那个。但你不希望拥有那个磁铁，那个小小的冰箱贴吗？所以在删减片段里，我们看到了这个物品？
Yes, I took a screen grab of it. So who has that now? I don't know, but Meredith is the one who, holds it up. She's like, did you guys get your little magnet? And it's a refrigerator. It's so cute. Angela, I love this refrigerator magnet that goes on your refrigerator so much that I would like you, please, because you're in charge of our merch. I am. I love it, you guys. If you ever have ideas, let me know. Well, I have one, so I'm letting you know, will you please make a refrigerator magnet with a little door that opens and inside the refrigerator is me and you?
是的，我截了图。那现在谁有它呢？我不知道，但梅雷迪思是举着它的人。她说，你们拿到你们的小磁铁了吗？那是一个冰箱。太可爱了。安吉拉，我太喜欢这个贴在冰箱上的冰箱贴了，所以我希望你，拜托，因为你负责我们的周边商品。我是。我喜欢它，伙计们。如果你们有什么想法，请告诉我。嗯，我有一个，所以我告诉你，请你做一个冰箱贴，带有一个可以打开的小门，冰箱里面是你和我好吗？
I don't know why we're in the refrigerator. I just want to be in there, okay? Okay. I can be holding a little jar of sourdough starter, and you can be holding something, too. A glass of wine. Sure. You open up the refrigerator to us, but you can put your own photo in there. Or we can just be on your refrigerator.
我不知道为什么我们在冰箱里。我只是想待在里面，好吗？好吧。我可以拿着一小罐酸种酵母，你也可以拿点什么。一杯红酒。当然。你打开冰箱看到我们，但你可以把自己的照片放进去。或者我们也可以直接贴在你的冰箱上。
We'd be happy to be there. To keep your company. Sure. Well, you guys, that was Phyllis's wedding. A huge thank you to Phyllis Smith for sending in those audio files. And of course, oh my gosh, thank you, Ken Whittingham. Yes, guys, we love you. We'll see you next week.
我们很乐意待在那里。陪伴你。当然。好吧，伙计们，这就是菲利斯的婚礼。非常感谢菲利斯·史密斯（Phyllis Smith）发来那些音频文件。当然，天哪，谢谢你，肯·惠廷汉姆。是的，伙计们，我们爱你们。我们下周见。
Yeah. Bye. Bye. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' second drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkens and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
再见。再见。感谢收听《办公室女士》的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的一档节目，由珍娜·费舍尔（Jenna Fisher）和安吉拉·金赛（Angela Kinsey）制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·乔肯斯（Cassie Jorkens），我们的音频工程师和副制片人是莫莉·纽金特（Molly Nugent）。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Shultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯（Leah Reese Dennis）。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨（Bill Shultz）进行混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿（Creed Bratton）的《Rubber Tree》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。